Hello，大家好，我是小军，今天我们的嘉宾是企业战略专
家曾明教授，呃，曾教授是阿里巴巴集团前总参谋长
也参与过两所商学院的创建，分别是长江商学院和湖畔
不过，一个他更令人熟识的身份，是一个对企业战略有深度思考
的人，呃，很多的创业者和企业家都说受过他的启发
作为完整经历过呃互联网周期的研究者呢
我们和他聊了聊，他对于 AI 新时代新范式的完整思考
并和历史上的关键时期都做了对照
听完让我觉得有了跟全局的视角
嗯，那接下来就是我对曾教授的访谈
如果大家喜欢我们的视频，请给我们点赞、投币、转发
一键三连
期待2026年，我们和 AI 共同进步
科层制管理的这种公司制度会衰亡
但也可能不叫公司，肯定不叫公司
肯定不叫公司，好，所以公司，肯定不叫公司
不叫，所以公司会消失，会公司会消亡
这这没有什么可以遗憾的呀，就将来有更好玩的
你说多少人现在去公司上班是开心的
呃，不开心
我也讲的比较尖锐一点，就是这一批的创业者要过的一个很大的
坎，因为经济学的基本规律，只要有同质化的供给
你就不可能获取高额利润，你就是一家不怎么值钱的公司
Google 不一定会成为下个时代的 Google
字节会是下个时代的字节吗
同样的，大概率也不会啊
字节今天模型做的也还不错，对吧
起码在国内是第一梯队的
没有啊，所以字节是有很大的机会成为 AI 云公司的
但是那个大的 to C 的应用是有非常大的不确定性的
豆包是吗
豆包肯定不是，对吧
要不然它肯定不不计成本的往里砸了
那它不砸了，就是因为豆包
不计成本的往里砸了，哎，它不砸了
就是因为堆包不够，不够那么未来啊
社交关系会重构吗
腾讯安全吗
肯定重构啊
腾讯作为最安全的，为什么最近这么恐慌
就是因为也有可能不安全了
人和人的关系会被重构，人的社交关系会重构
那人和货物的关系呢
一样会被重构
我觉得阿里也一样有那个挑战
在这波巨浪面前啊，哪些巨头是安全的
我从来觉得在巨浪面前没有人是安全
你觉得他们 all in AI
还能够成为下一个时代的企业吗
就是时代性的企业吗
挑战非常大
红利时里面有依据可言吗
就这个时代企业过渡到下一个时代企业
还能做的非常好的多不多
不是多不多的问题，是有没有的问题
哦，有没有啊
基本没有
哎，所以这种不依赖于你怎么战略选择
你都很难一直在派桌上，是吗
就是这个是让人绝望的地方
这一点都不让人绝望啊
就是人有生老病死，公司也有生老病死
没有比这更
人有生老病死，公司也有生老病死
没有比这更正常的了
所以新公司才有机会，年轻人才有
才有梦想
曾教授，我听很多企业家都提到过您啊
他们说自己某次的很重要的一个战略转型
可能来自于在湖畔大学上过您的课
那商学院的教授有很多，我在想，为什么这么多企业家都说受过
您的影响
你觉得您和其他商学院教授的不同是什么呀
呃，我觉得首先啊，我特别特别幸运
就在互联网发展最快的时候，有机会加入阿里
参与了一个公司超高速发展的一个一个阶段
所以那段经历，加上我原来有很好的学术的训练
这这两个的结合，就让我把理论跟实践给融合起来了
因为我在做的时候，我也经常想，我以前自己讲的东西
到底哪些东西能用
啊，然后在做的过程中也会去提炼
有什么新东西是可以变成一个理论框架将
新东西，是可以变成一个理论框架
将来还能继续用的
所以这个理论跟实践的结合是一个很大的突破
然后第二点呢，就是我一直在持续的研究前沿的产业发展
所以跟创业者聊天的时候呢，就除了能跟他们讨论战略的方法论
还能跟他们一起探讨，就下一步产业到底会怎么发展
啊，你做什么样的战略决定可能更合适
嗯
所以把这两者结合到一起，也是挺稀缺的一种能力
哎，那像以阿里为例，因为这个是您亲身参与最长时间的一个公
司
过去20年，您觉得影响阿里真正生死存亡的战略决策有吗
它会是哪几个呀
啊，我最近正好也在做个复盘，所以我对阿里前面十五年比较因
为完整的参与过嘛，实际上可能最重要的决定就是3个：创立淘
宝、创立支付宝、创立阿里云
而且这3个决定不但当时在整个社会是不被认可的
嗯，公司内部的争议也非常非常的激烈
就大家可能对阿里云的这个争议已经有很多的了解了
但是淘宝宣布成立的时候，当时是有好几个高管是非常非常反对
的，为什么呀
觉得原来阿里巴巴的业务都还没有成熟
然后你去打一倍的核心的主营业务
风险太大了，嗯，所以这个最重要的就这3个决定
然后可能稍微次要一点的，像淘宝从怎么从一个商品买卖的平台
变成一个支持电子商务发展的生态
啊，然后怎么 O 印无线，我觉得这两个决定其实也很重要
嗯，但是重要性可能没那么大，但我刚刚讲的
就是说后面还要补充一点，其实你做了这个战略以后
还有一层一层的决定，四级战略决定也很重要
嗯，就比如
四级战略决定，也很重要
嗯，就比如说阿里云早期，你是只服务于一个场景
还是一开始架构就要是多服务场景
啊，你服务的那个场景是服务淘宝还是服务搜索
嗯，然后开源还是闭源，这个都是争论非常非常大的二级战略问
题
啊，然后再往下，还有你基这个数据库变了
那你要不要自己做数据库
啊，然后计算也变了，然后存储也变了
所以才会出现当时喊出来的去 IOE
就是改掉 I B M Oracle 跟这个 EMC
EMC 就存储
嗯
所以就像今天一样，计算完了以后
发现存储成了一个新的瓶颈
啊，所以呢，其实战略到落地的过程中
它有很多很重要的决定
越到下面，越是战略跟战术结合很紧密的地方
所以不是做了一个大的战略决定就可以了
它是它从它从一个决定到落地到
可以了，它是它从它从一个决定到落地
到最后看到成果，是有非常非常大的一个挑战的
战略做决策的那个时刻，你们怎么知道这是一个好战略呢
因为当时的争议也非常多
战略，因为做很多的战略，你们怎么判断它是一个好的战略
不知道啊，因为相信所以看见了
哦，所有的好的真正就是成为时代的企业
的都是最后被证明了，它那个反共识是成立的
嗯，当然在这个过程中也有很多疯狂的想法其实就没有了
这这点是一定要去强调的，不是疯狂的想法
我们看到的就是所谓的 survival bias
就你看到的是这个成功者的偏差，最成功的企业一定是反共识的
啊，但反共识不一定成功
但是在当时呢，我们基于我们自己的能力
能看到而且也愿意相信的，就是那样一个图
嗯
所以战略很大程度上是其实是关于怎么创造未来的
它不是一个简单的一个规划
关于怎么创造未来的，它不是一个简单的一个规划
只有反共识的战略才能够大成吗
有没有共识性的战略能够大成呢
就是我我在一个共识赛道，但是我做的比所有人都强
它能大成吗
那就是优秀嘛
哦，那就是优秀，是不是卓越
是的
呃，卓越一定来自反共识
那今天这个 AI 时代，我们进入了一个全新的周期范式阶段
也像您说的，这是一个新的文明
您会感觉到迷茫、焦虑吗
就是像您这样一个要制定战略的人
看到未来的时候，你这个时候的感受是什么样的
的确是非常非常的困惑，因为你知道肯定是有很多的新东西会出
现，嗯，但你不知道哪一些是稍纵即逝的小浪花
哪一些是代表未来的大的浪潮，什么东西会变
什么东西不会变，这个是非常非常让人困惑的
您现在看到哪些是小浪花，哪些是大浪啊
有没有一些初步的想法和判断
这就是我为什么写这本书的原因，是因为前面几年都在琢磨这个
事情，嗯
写这本书的原因，是因为前面几年都在琢磨这个事情
嗯，就经常会有一些观察和洞见，觉得还不错的
但是可能很快又被否定掉了
但是今年上半年就比较明显，就有11些趋势性的信号开始 c
onverge，就是开始出现了类似的信号
然后我看到了一个可能的框架，嗯
是可以去解释当下发生的很多事情
甚至去推演推演未来下一步的发展的
所以我觉得，哎，这个时候我就不太焦虑了
因为我大概理解了我们在哪个发展阶段
然后知道到底该怎么做事情
对我们这次聊天的缘由，也是您最近出了一本新书
呃，智能，你也说就是这个书，其实开始没有写作计划
是自然涌现出来的，也是最最近半年的通过的一系列的思考
想清楚了很多的问题
呃，您能不能给大家介绍一下这本书
然后已经的创作过程
我自己的这个本意是，在书，然后已经的创作过程
我自己的和这个本业是战略嘛，嗯
所以其实跟创业者聊的最多的就是 AI 时代面临这么大的不
确定性，啊，这么快速变化的环境
到底怎么做战略
所以这个是开始慢慢想的比较清楚的
但真正让整个框架浮现出来的，是我觉得我大概理解了 AI
在产业化进入了哪一个发展阶段，然后每个阶段的不同的运行规
律
我觉得这个看清楚了呢，大概对未来35年就有一个比较清晰的
指导意义了
所以今天的人工智能产业化发展到什么阶段了
您是怎么划分这完整的阶段的
我其实做过一个很系统的研究，就是从移动互联网到 PC 互
联网，然后再到 PC 啊，然后包括当时我做云计算的时候
其实是把第一次工业革命、第2次工业革命、第3次工业革命
其实整个历史也都研究过一遍
所以呢，就大致呢，其实新技术的出现
我讲的都
大致呢，其实新技术的出现，我讲的都是巨大的通用技术的颠覆
性创新
嗯
实际上都经历了3个阶段，特别有意思
就第一个阶段就是这个技术逐渐的被社会接受
然后它成了这个社会的基础设施，这是第一步
嗯
啊
第二步呢，基于这个基础设施产生了海量的新的应用
嗯
就是百花齐放的时代
然后第3个呢是，当这些海量的应用出现以后
大家发现我们需要一些更底层的方法去运行这个新的世界
这就进入了第3个阶段，就我把第3个阶段叫做原生应用的阶段
嗯
哎，像以移动互联网为例，到了抖音、字节
它属于原生应用的阶段
是的
对，就是说，早期就是说，比如说移动互联网
大家可能今天，现在年轻的人可能听说过黑莓手机的可能都很少
了
嗯
但是黑莓手机的可能都很少了，嗯
但是黑莓手机是第一款被称为智能手机的
而且它在很长时间是垄断地位的，而且市场增长率、渗透率也很
高，一直到2010年，它还是美国市场智能手机的40%几的
市场占有份额，iPhone 只有20%几
实际上是到 iPhone 4以后
iPhone 才开始领先，开始跑起来的
所以其实这个第一阶段、第二阶段
然后有了 iPhone 以后，有了 App Store
App Store 以后出现了这些新一代的原生应用
然后早期的时候，其实我那时候投互联网嘛
投移动互联网嘛，其实还有墨迹天气啊什么的
这个一堆的应用，当时日活很快都过亿了
但是会很快的发现，其实它们不代表未来
真正是要解决核心需求的主流的应用才是那个原生应用
为什么要先经过一个应用大爆发，再到原生应用
那为什么原生应用不是诞生于第二阶段呀
到原生应用，那为什么原生应用不是诞生于第二阶段呀
因为应用的爆发，给了技术下一阶段发展的方向
就技术成为基础设施以后，并不是停滞不前了
它要寻找自己新的发展方向
但到底往哪方向发展，其实是不清楚的
其实就像我刚刚讲的这个字节，其实是先做了今日头条
甚至在那之前还做了内涵段子，一堆的小的产品
是因为在那个技术的早期，你不知道哪个东西能 work
所以你要试不同的东西
第一阶段那个时候只有文字成熟了
所以才会出现今日头条
嗯
但是今日头条探索出了推荐算法，这样的一种新的啊
既是技术模式又是商业模式
然后又由于带宽啊、这个算力啊各方面的发展
才出现了短视频
然后短视频的这个新的展现形式和推荐算法这个底层技术
新的展现形式和推荐算法这个底层技术
这两者一结合，才出现了抖音这样的现象级的原生应用
真正出现了国民级的应用
所以原生应用距离基础设施成熟中间还有一个过渡性的阶段
能把第二阶段叫做过渡阶段吗
呃，这样说，好多中间那部分创业者好伤心啊
所以我为什么会犹豫
就说，说第二阶段本身是非常精彩
也非常有价值的
就是所以为什么我说原生阶段是第三阶段
其实就想告诉大家，其实还有可能8年也好
10年也好，非常精彩的时间是属于第二阶段的
嗯
你没办法跨越到第三阶段
就跨不过去了，就没有第二阶段的积累
就你跨不到第三阶段
而且基于第第一阶段的积累，现在该做的就是第二阶段该做的应
用大爆发的事情
我们现在在 AI 的这个产业周期里是结束了第一阶段吗
还是在第一阶段，还是在第二阶段开始
具体在哪个时间点上
觉得吧，还是在第一阶段，还是在第二阶段开始
我觉得2026年应该是第一阶段基本完成的一个标志性的阶段
嗯
核心原因就是今年年初，大家可能还记得
就是关于 token 这个词形成了一个广泛的共识
是吧
有两三个月的讨论非常密集
黄仁勋在英伟达的 GTC 大会上就讲
啊，英伟达的未来就是 token factory
啊
然后 Sam 也马上表达，OpenAI 核心就是卖 to
ken 的，啊
然后这个 token 为什么重要呢
就是包括词元这个新词被定义下来
是因为当一个技术有了一个标准的度量衡以后
它就能被规模化、的标准化的使用
所以，我们今天会讲一度电，对吧
这个一吨水，啊，一个 GB 的流量
对吧
这些是让我们可以很简单的使用一个原来曾经很前沿的这个技术
那今天大家都知道，我掉多少 token
我能干多少活
我能干多少活，它让我产生多少费用
这个事情它就成了社会的基础设施
所以这是第一阶段的尾巴
呃，第一阶段开始成熟的表现，它会继续发展
对吧
服务会越来越好，智能会越来越强大
成本会越来越低，但是它形成了一个匹配的商业模式
而且成了大家能接受的一种新概念
所以这个阶段是成熟了
我们到第二阶段了吗
今年有意思的地方是，它也是第二阶段的一个开场
啊，对吧
因为今年春节前后同样发生的另外一个特别让大家兴奋的事情
就是 Open crawl，就龙虾
大家都在养龙虾，春节都没睡好，对吧
对吧
天天都疯狂一样的在弄这些东西
那龙虾让大家看到了什么
其实是看到了一个能够独立完成任务的 agent 的无限的
潜力，啊，所以大家大家才会这么狂
的无限的潜力，啊，所以大家大家才会这么狂热
嗯，所以我认为 AI 进入的第2个阶段
就是智能体阶段
智能体就是 AI 时代的新应用
嗯，所以第一阶段已经成熟，然后我们现在站在第二阶段的开端
是的，是的
如果类比到，比如说互联网哪一年
移动互联的哪一年，今今天可以做一个这样的类比吗
当然这个有点刻舟求剑，但是我们还是想类比一下
对，是这个，这个这是我琢磨了两三年的问题
其实我3年前、两年前还做过讲演
就是让我们拥抱雅虎吧，雅虎快来了
然后今年年初的时候，我自己也觉得有点有点纠结
是我们怎么退回到了浏览器阶段，还比雅虎还要早了
就是您的判断更加前移，是更加前移了
哦，就是因为我当时看到 Open Cloud 这些东西出
来以后，我第一个反应，啊，就是就是我们还在等一个浏览器出
来，这都不是浏览器出来以后，我们在等一个浏览器出来
就为什么会有这样
出来以后，我们在等一个浏览器出来
就为什么会有这样的一个洞察呢
就是因为，就后面就是跟 agent 同时出现的一个词是
scale，对吧
能力
那我们去想 agent 的本质是什么
其实就是分享能力，对吧
我们把我们懂的能力封装起来，然后分享出去
让别人也可以使用，啊
然后 OpenCLoud 提供了一个框架和思路
原来能力是可以这样被封装、被调用的
哎，我就突然想到，92年的时候
我最狂热的是什么
是建个网站啊，哦，对吧
那时候就是建网站啊，就所有的人都是想着建个网站
然后建网站的目的是什么
就是去分享信息啊
嗯
所以 AGI 这轮的创新，就是让我们从信息时代进入了能力
时代
啊，海量的信息和知识都处理完了
所以今天分享信息已经没有必要了
大家都直接问 ChatGPT 答案了
大家不再找信息了
但是今天大模型能有这个成就，是因为92年的建站运动
让大家把信息都放到互联网上了，完成了信息的数字化的过程啊
所以我们做类比的关键，就是我们什么时候做类比
没有刻舟求剑，是我们去理解抽象建模以后
理解它的一个底层运行规律，而不是纠缠于技术的表现形式
对吧
所以当我想到大家都是在建，一个在建站
一个在建 Agent，然后一个是分享信息
一个是分享能力
我觉得这个结构上就对上了啊
浏览器为什么重要
在那个时代是一个新的阶段，浏览器是完成了两个核心功能
通过 HTML 啊这一堆的事情
就是说树立了建站的一个非常简单的统一标准
所以建站就没有门槛了，就有信息的人就能建站
原来建站是一个专业工程师的专业工作
嗯
能建站，原来建站是一个专业工程师的专业工作
嗯，所以他把这个创造的门槛极大的降低了
也就是我们今天讲的开发者的门槛大幅降低了
然后另外一方面呢，他把浏览网站的门槛降到了零
就是因为你只需要点击，就能完成所有的信息浏览的过程
所以你一下用户端就爆了，然后供给端也爆了
然后就出现了无穷的网站天天涌现
然后大家都不知道该看啥了，这个时候就出现了雅虎
雅虎最早就是一个目录，告诉你今天出现的这100个网站里头
这个网站最有意思，到了后面出了一万个网站的时候
就告诉你前面10个最有最有趣的是什么
然后再给你分类，娱乐、新闻、股票
这个就开始分类了，所以雅虎其实是一个结构化信息的一个过程
对啊，对啊，它就是个目录，它是在商减
它不是在商增，对吧
商增的同时一定要有商减，降低大家的认知压力
那我们今天还在一个商
商减降低大家的认知压力
那我们今天还在一个商增的过程中
就是各种的 skill 能力的爆发
对啊，因为我们随便问身边任何人
大家都不会随口跟你讲出两三个他天天在用的 agent
那您觉得谁会有能做商减这个事情的潜质啊
您看到一些雅虎的雏形没有
是 Open Cloud 这种形态吗
没有，我完全没有看到雅虎的雏形
所以我说连浏览器现在都没出现
所以如果你让我拍脑袋说的话，我觉得下一个下一个最大的机会
就是一个类似浏览器这样的机会
嗯
是它会把 agent 的标准统一起来
然后同时能够让用户用很简单的方法就能调用 agent
嗯
然后会有海量的 agent 爆发
这个可能就是未来两年可能最让人兴奋的一件事情
今天没有任何这样的雏形吗
所以这也是个反共识嘛，就大家大家都觉得好像谈
就龙虾也是昙花一现，好像现在也没人谈应用了
呃，龙虾也是昙花一现，好像现在也没人谈应用了
但我讲的这个可能非常乐观啊
但我的确是，所以我们基于历史的推演形成一个抽象的模型
去思考未来
然后底层的我能看到的就是这样一个演化的路径
所以在这个意义上，我就不焦虑了
我就在等着这些发生就好了
嗯，哎，那假想一下，这样的一个产品形态可能是什么样的呀
它的先决条件可能是什么
交互形态是想象不出来的，这就需要大家去创造
我们能总结出一个抽象的规律，但是我们一定推演不出一个具体
的形态
雅虎到 Google 还有几年呢
你没有看到雅虎，应该也没有看到这个时代的 Google
对吧
这是我现在没法回答的问题，因为我不太确定我们这个时代是不
是一定会有雅虎跟 Google 巨大的鸿沟
因为雅虎后面就没有了嘛
嗯
然后这个我觉得，我现在看不清，我也觉得太早了
不用讨论
嗯
我们等看到了雅虎，让
我觉得太早了，不用讨论
嗯，我们得看到了雅虎，让雅虎先辉煌3年
我们大概才能看到谁想去挑战雅虎
就雅虎95年，95年成立，一直到2000年都是辉煌的
这个 Google 成立了以后
是给雅虎做 To B 的服务商的
是给他们提供那个算法的服务的，就是雅虎下面一个小弟弟帮他
提供一个技术支持而已
嗯，在这个意义上是雅虎孕育了 Google
那这个时代的关键的变量是模型啊
您是怎么理解模型的
模型的本质是什么
它可以类比于什么
有很多可以类比的，就比如说大家讲数据是新时代的石油
嗯，对吧
那模型实际上是一个炼油厂，广泛提供基础设施这个角度讲
它又有点像另外一个消失了的公司
美国在线 AOL，它是互联网基础接入服务商
它让所有的人都能够接到互联网上
这个本身就是一个很
让所有的人都能够接到互联网上，这个本身就是一个很巨大的一
个工程
那今天大模型是让所有的人都可以很轻易的接入到智能的一个路
口
嗯
所以在这个意义上，它也是个基础设施服务商
所以你觉得模型公司是一个基础设施服务商
它能类比为哪些公司
就比如今天的 OpenAI、Andrepic、Kimi、
Deepseek 这些公司
我我觉得说的直白一点，就是 AI 云公司
就就是未来的 AI 云公司
嗯
然后这是为什么现在，比如说这几个大模型公司跟几家云厂商的
博弈，在美国变得非常的有趣和复杂
是因为云厂商觉得他们付出了太多
得到了太少，对吧
然后模型公司可能大概率认为，他们自己将来要自建云服务
甚至要自研芯片，对吧
像 OpenAI 这样的
所以这两个生态之间可能会
像 OpenAI 这样的，所以这两个生态之间可能会发生一
些碰撞跟重新整合，然后会形成几个比较稳定的 AI 云公司
那个是确定的
然后大模型公司有没有机会从基础服务提供商变成一家成功的应
用公司
嗯，我觉得这是个开放的问题
如果我主观的给个结论呢，概率不会太高
为什么
没有历史上的先例啊
Codex 现在就做得很好啊，Claude 做的很好啊
没有啊，这是大模型的一个基础，一个延伸啊
这是 Coding 要成为基础智能的一部分啊
对吧
如果没有 Coding 的话，我们今天都谈不上可以调用
API，就就就 Token 就不会成立了
嗯
是因为有了 Coding 的这个能力以后
才让 Token 变得这么有价值的
因为它智能程度，它推理这个智能突破了呀
但是你看一下啊，Drop 就是这样的公司
它成立才不到10年吧，短短几年就已经市值0亿美金的公司
这人的历史上都非常的罕见
你怎么解释这个
就已经市值0亿美金的公司，在人类历史上都非常的罕见
你怎么解释这个现象
这个描述本身就是一个幻觉和误解
就是因为年轻人容易认为每个时代这一次不一样
这就是典型的这次不一样
其实我去专门查过这个事情啊，就回到我们刚刚讲雅虎
雅虎95年成立，2000年的时候达到了1200亿市值美元
的市值，5年的时间，那个相当于什么呢
那时候的1000亿美元的市值大概相当于我们今天的一万亿美
元
你把通货膨胀把这个纳值的基本算进去
就是那时候11000~11000千美元
按大概8%的年回报，就是今天一万亿美元的公司
所以在2000年能达到1000亿美元
5年不比今天的 tropek 对大家的震撼不强烈
一样强烈
然后我刚讲的那个消失掉的公司 AOL
1988年开始提供服务，2000年高点的时候是2200亿
公美元的估值，比雅虎还高，是当时市值最高的一家公司
然后他再去收购了传统的媒体，收购华纳
是吧
达到3000多亿美金，所以也是一个很恐怖的数字
然后谷歌是98年成立的，2005年达到1000亿美元
黑莓公司，就是它的巅峰，它也是一个硬件厂家
最快达到千亿美金估值的公司
嗯
所以，其实当一个技术有这么大的冲击力的时候
第一波成功跑出来的公司就有这么大的价值
所以我觉得，就是说，esrpek 啊
open ai 啊，这个是了不起的技术上的突破跟商业上的
成绩
但是这样的先例在历史上，在类似的阶段
都发生过
但是它不一定能活到最后，但但很可能会往后活的不错
但它大概率不是原生应用阶段的大玩家、大赢家
即使是回到我们讲的这个石油的这个比喻
炼油厂跟化工厂其实也是两类企业
嗯
就化工企业后面比纯粹炼油的企业要有价值的多
化工就是应用，炼油就是最基础的
把这个把石油给开采出来，然后再变成一个基础的油
对吧
然后就像这还有个类比，就比如说汽车
汽车离开了石油肯定不转，对吧
但是你石油公司肯定做不了汽车
你没听说过哪个是汽车公司是由石油公司转化的
我昨天刚好还看了一下，就是陆奇博士在2024年时候说过的
一段话：Open AI 就是这种 AGI 公司
未来一定会比 Google 大
只是大5倍还是大10倍的问题
以您刚才的论述的话，我觉得您不仅不认为 Open AI
可能
以您刚才的论述的话，我觉得您不仅不认为 OpenAI 可
能是新时代 AI 时代的谷歌，甚至觉得他们可能只是一个类
似于历史上的过客的这样的公司嘛
他们甚至会消失，是这么观点吗
我是这个观点，我我相信未来会有一定会有一个100000亿
美元的公司，但是未必是现在领跑的这两家公司
嗯，其实我理解陆奇博士想说的就是未来会有一家 AI 时代
的谷歌公司，它很可能比现在谷歌大10倍
不，他说的是 OpenAI
我理解，我只是说，但但是那不是大家大概只想得到 AI 会
代表到未来
但是我我是因为纯粹我自己是一个商业史的研究者
最近也有说开玩笑，就是说因为硅谷现在最时髦的那个词或者说
地位最高的词叫 researcher 嘛
对吧
一讲 researcher，大家就很尊重
嗯
然后我觉得我现在也可以 claim
我也是个 researcher
我只是研究商业世界的动力学规律啊
然后我们能看到的
动力学规律啊，然后我们能看到的
我能看到的理论框架告诉我的就是
第一阶段的企业很难活到第二阶段
第二阶段的企业很难活到第三阶段
哎，为什么第一阶段企业很难活到第二阶段
第二阶段企业活到第三阶段
按理说他们这么早就在这个市场上
然后他对最前沿的信息也是最敏锐的
他为什么不能及时转型呢
比如说我马上从一家基础设施公司转型成为一家 agency
公司，这个很顺畅啊，我觉得
不顺畅，是因为第一阶段的技术核心是可不可用
所以它有很多的原创的技术的创新
第二阶段开始的标志是第一阶段的技术发展渐渐缓慢下来
然后才能变成大家都能调用的技术
我就不用再去重新开发轮子了
然后第二阶段的应用其实是需要很强的洞察力
它要的是产品很强的原创力，然后跟普通用户的那种同理心
然后需要应用技术的一堆的新的东西
嗯
就说你可以把那个应用技术的那堆新东西叫做新时代的大模型也
可以，就说它其实是有新的很多技术前沿的创新
就比如说，比如说这个上下文的管理
这个事情，它有很多的技术创新可以做
这个你到底把它定义为大模型还是不是大模型
嗯
其实不是那么清楚的啊
然后在这里后面，其实包括 AI 也有很多新的范式会出来
就比如说现在出来很多新的 new lab
对吧
新的 new lab 里面一部分的人可能就会去转向支持这
个阶段的应用需要的新技术
这两个的结合可能就变成了第二阶段的王者
所以技术依然在进步，但是技术未必沿着原来的轨迹在线性的增
长
嗯
它可能也有一个技术的范式的变化
您觉得不管是中国还是美国，最也有个技术的范式的变化
您觉得，不管是中国还是美国，最后模型公司的一个格局会形成
什么样的一个状态呀
非常简单，公共基础设施的行业只有一种模式
商业模式是成立的，叫寡头垄断加政府强监管
因为整个社会依赖于它，所以政府一定会强监管
第2个，由于这个供给如此重要，所以不能只有一个供应商
然后呢，由于这个基础设施投入这么大
所以肯定不会无序竞争，不会有很多供应商
所以就是经典的寡头竞争，政府强监控
保证社会有稳定的低成本的供给，这才叫基础设施
对吧
你现在水电费能随便涨价吗
当然不能了
我知道这个现实对很多现在创业的人很残酷
那像比如说 OpenAI、Anthropic、呃 Goo
gle 呃的模型，您觉得它们都会并存
就这里面有优劣之分吗
当然有优劣之分，这是这个阶段最有价值的竞
优劣之分吗
当然有优劣之分，这是这个阶段最有价值的竞争
就我讲那个产业中局，并不否定现阶段的这些重要性和这些企业
了不起的地方
而且今今年，呃，特别是 OpenAI 先领跑
OpenAI 在跟上，谷歌阶段性的被甩下
其实就是组织能力跟技术能力其实出现了一些差距
然后像 XAI 跟 Meta 就直接退出竞赛了
嗯
就在寡头过程中，已经有人已经退场
掉队了
嗯
对啊，退掉队了
这也是我想问你的，为什么 XAI 和 Meta 会掉队
看起来他们资源很多啊
对
呃
老板也很重视，对吧
也算是一把手工程吧
呃，这个可能就跟我新书里面讲到那个智能复利有关
那个基本概念有关
嗯
我觉得 OpenAI 从去年下半年可能到今年上半年开始
让大家意识到比较清楚的是，他们开始用大模型训练大模型了
也就是 AI 进入了他们的
大模型了，也就是 AI 进入了他们的主业叫大模型训练
啊，然后呢，他们把 AI 这个工具用到了自己的主业上
所以他们模型训练的能力大幅提升
这是为什么我们会这个今年上半年大家会如此兴奋
是因为发现大模型还可以用这么快的速度提升这么高的性能
这个就是因为大模型本身进入了它的训练过程
但是还没有到现在又还是很火的那个词叫完全自我驱动的那个
self-learning，还没到那个阶段
它只是局部的被使用了，但已经产生了很大的价值
实际上这两家公司也有组织上的优势
像今年讨论的同样多的，有很多的文章讨论 Anthropi
c 的组织优势，啊，战略上的聚焦
然后这些呢是相对来说其他几个公司可能就比较弱的
所以当你组织优势跟一个新的技术的运营方式结合在一起的时候
它就产生了一个
运营方式结合在一起的时候，它就产生了一个巨大的领先优势
而这个领先优势真的已经开始把比较弱的玩家往后甩出去了
中国的这些模型公司呢，他们会怎么进一步演化
中国跟美国是保持两个不太一样的生态
我觉得中国模型公司会持续的追赶和发展
但是中国模型之间公司之间的竞争也会有点类似美国公司
就这几家大大小小的公司，最后比如说今年年底
谁如果跑不到3T 的模型，估计谁就出局了
它是个淘汰赛，就像现在世界杯一样的
就是说你可能现在是八进四，啊，然后接下来四进二
啊，八进四的时候，大概率的确会开始淘汰
所以最后留下有限的几家，成为一个基础设施
这是您的观点
是的，嗯，现在看起来谁淘汰了
美国我们知道了，中国呢
中国其实就是看年底嘛，年底3T
现在大家卯足了劲都在搞这个嘛
嗯，K 3刚刚到了2
8T
对，是差不多等于是，等于是质谱有点领跑
然后 Kim 在3T 上先交卷
成绩基本满意，再接下来看 Mini Max 啊
前文肯定很快会发，对吧
然后 Mini Max 啊这些
差不多就都都是都在跑这个最基本的这个新的新的晋级线
模型的格局今年会稳定下来吗
还真不一定哦，就是可能要到前两名、前三名的优势基本跟后面
拉大了以后，这两三家可能就不太容易再拉开了
就是您说的那个黑洞理论
对
要形成一个巨大的黑洞效应，对其他家很难再超越
对，其实 Soroptic 跟这个呃 OpenAI 在美
国其实就从智能复利的这个飞轮开始
嗯，因为他们会继续的往 self
开始，嗯，因为他们会继续的往 serve improvi
ng 的这个路上去走，所以这个差距是越拉越大的
所以他们其实有点形成了黑洞效应
这也是为什么美国的云厂家就有点慌了
就是说，因为因为要看，因为将来这两者之间什么合作关系就变
得非常重要了
那在您看来，做模型的窗口期关闭了没有
新公司还应该在做模型吗
以我们定义的作为基础设施的大模型公司的窗口肯定是关闭了
哎，因为已经进入到了竞争的接近智能飞轮都已经跑起来的阶段
了，你这进来就完全完全没有积累了
那这些模型公司最后是会趋同还是会分化
寡头竞争的特征就是有一定的差异化
但是又足够的同质化
同质化是保证可以被替代，差异化是让大家还有钱赚
所以模型公司是好生意吗
是个很好的成熟生意，就我们为什么说企业都是时代的企业
是个很好的成熟生意，就是我们为什么说企业都是时代的企业
嗯，就是你肯定不会是当红炸子鸡了
过个35年，就是就是如果你真的真的没有进入下一个阶段竞争
你就是成了一个大家都调用你的服务
大家只会不稳定的时候 complain
不会天天夸你的
OK，您觉得未来35年可能会看到这个新的迹象
应该能看到
哦，那接接下来，如果他们是基础设施服务商
那接下来一个阶段会我们会看见什么呢
什么样的公司会成为新的时代的公司
就是看谁是 Next Step
谁是雅虎啊，谁把 Agent 的标准建立起来
谁抢住了 Agent 的用户入口啊
嗯，这个观点都跟我们今天想象的其实很非共识
所以，就像你现在去 Web 大会里头
只有在地下一层一小块区域才能看到做应用的这些公司
嗯
就2层、3层的大厂家全部都是做的是现在有公司的东西
嗯，这个有，其实，是2026年的一个快照
Web 大会快照
东西，嗯，这个有趣，这是2026年的一个快照
那个大会快照
您觉得3年后会变成什么呀
您大胆预想一下
我觉得3年是有可能开始出现 agent 的路口
就是因为 agent 太多了
你想想，咱们就换了一个普通人的角度
你怎么知道哪个 agent 能用
你敢不敢把一件重要的事情交给 agent
你钱包敢交给 agent 吗
啊，你个人的隐私敢交给 agent 吗
然后这种信任从何而来
对吧
然后我怎么知道他收我的费用是真实的
这些东西其实都需要有一个可能，一个新的服务商来给大家建立
这种信任
嗯
让我们愿意说 OK，那我相信你定的标准
对吧
我相信你的推荐，然后我相信里面的 agent
我是敢用的
好用不好用，那是我后面自己的选择
那这是我们接下来要聊的一个话题
就是 agent
嗯，您觉得 agent 现在应该已经爆发了
对吧
你怎么看
它现在
就是 A 管理，嗯，您觉得 A 管理现在应该已经爆发了
对吧
你怎么看它现在的一个状态
现在就是百花齐放啊，大家各显神通
大家都在找那个切入点
就因为其实就说真正的叫 A 管理
去年就有人喊 A 管理元年嘛，对吧
然后也有很多 A 管理的创业
我其实去年夏天在硅谷就已经经历了第一波 A 管理的火爆
就是说去任何个 demo day
对吧
基本上都是十几个项目，对吧
都是各种各样的 A 管理在那，偶尔有几个做 infra
的，对吧
在做做基础设施的，对吧
但大部分都是做应用的，对
但是那些应用其实今年都不怎么样了
对吧
是因为去年的应用真的做的都是特别简单的任务
就我看一场10个演这个 demo 里头
大概会有35个是做广告的，然后里头有的就是做一个素材生成
的，然后里头有的就是做一个素材生成
有的就是做一个投放，就这么简单的事情
我当时就觉得不太可能有长期价值
对吧
但是当时我比如说我看到有家企业开始想做增长
哎，我觉得这个事情可能就有前途
为什么
因为增长很复杂，就它得做复杂任务
得做复杂任务啊，智能你才有可能建立自己的智能闭环啊
然后你才会有可能做一堆的你自己个有价值的技术积累
而不是搭脚手架呀
就是说，当智能能力不够的时候，你做应用很大程度上是在做脚
手架，然后等着模型自然溢出把你脚手架就淹没了
但是今天做应用的切入点和思路是需要完全不同的
就是你要假定智能是完全够用的，然后它到底能干啥活
所以今天的核心是干活，然后是干一个复杂的活
就越简单的活越容易被复杂的活越容易被复杂的活给吞掉
因为它没有多少成长的空间，这个是干完了就干完了
那那不就停在那边了吗
那像 Minus 这样去年说做通用智能体的
呃，产品形态，你怎么看呢
我有一阵子没有接触他们了，不知道他们下一步发展的思路是什
么
但是 Minus 当时的确是市场感觉非常敏锐
嗯，因为他们其实抓住了 coding 溢出的这个啊特别难
得的一个机会窗，啊，但是他们的定位就是通用 agent
那么通用 agent 当时能触达到的
就是一批 prosumer 的生产力的需求
啊，那当时那个切入点是对的，在今天一个 agent 要站
得住，至少要找个10倍以上的切入点
你才有发展的空间
什么叫10倍以上的切入点
就是比那个应用场景要大10倍以上的
就是，就是说，比如说，大家做做 PPT 啊
然后出个报告啊，那些都不够大
而今天技术又往前拱了一步，智能程度又拱了一步
做长程规划这些都比以前进步了很多
那你能不能够往前大大走一步，把一个复杂任务给解决了
那需要进入一个垂直场景吗
就是要做通用的 AIGC，还是做垂直的 AIGC
这个就是大家接下来比创造力、比这个天分的地方
就比如说这个教育、健康，这是典型的大垂类
对
你只要在里面耕耘就够了
你是在这个垂类里面能不能找到一个足够好的切入点
嗯
现在能切得进去，将来能长得大的
但是通用的里头又会分 To B 跟 To C
对吧
然后 To B 里头哪个是关键
这个又不一样了
我觉得到今年年底
关键，这个又不一样了
我觉得到今年年底，你就会听到一堆的要做组织大脑的 age
nt，组织大脑就是 agent 嘛
对啊，组织的操作系统就不同的叫法了
对啊，就操作系统，或者是说 CEO 的 agent 的这
个团队，这个肯定是今年很火的一个主赛道了
那这是 To B 端的，To B 端的
To C 端的
To C 端的从又开始重新做情情感陪伴啊
然后解决问题的啦，这些就都开始出现了
很多人都说这一波的就是应用啊，它很难形成上一代互联网、移
动互联网时代那种数据飞轮
你怎么看这个现象
你觉得它应该去追求数据飞轮吗
数据飞轮升级到了智力飞轮，就是智能的飞轮
对啊，就是这个讲的智能复利
所以今天大家其实也在讲数据飞轮啊
数据飞轮是一直存在的
是其实互联网更特别的是网络效应啊
我们先讲这个
是，其实互联网更特别的是网络效应啊
我们先讲这个数据飞轮到智能飞轮
是因为，就说，你要真正把数据飞轮跑起来
就像今天的这个巨声机器人一样的
你其实相应也要有算法的创新，也要有应用场景
所以这也是个三结合的东西
然后我们刚讲到的那个智能复利也是
你要形成一个新的学习场景，就你调用了基础这个智能
但是你是让 agent 具备一个更高的智能
去完成一个特定的任务
然后在这个特定的任务过程中，它一定会有数据的飞轮
然后因为数据飞轮的前提是真实世界的反馈嘛
对吧
真实世界的反馈的前提是，你这个 agent 要能独立去干
活嘛，要离开人的这个参与嘛，啊
然后这个中间呢，一定会有算法的创新
包括刚才讲到的广义的，就是包括上下文的管理
包括记忆，对吧
包括这个新的
力包括记忆，对吧
包括这个新的交互方式这些，然后这个会形成一个智能的复利
它在这个场景下就变得越来越聪明
然后这个智能复利能够渗透延伸到什么其他的场景去解决更复杂
的任务，那个就是它的发展路径
然后找到了，或者运气好撞上了最有规模化、最能泛化的那个场
景的人，就最有可能形成黑洞效应
它就有可能跑出来，进入第三阶段的竞争
哦，这需要好多的条件，才能够达成一个原生应用的产生
对吧
对啊
现在看到这样的好的场景了吗
应该还没有
没有啊，没有啊
要要有的话，肯定就火了，大家就肯定都会抢着去用嘛
就是你看，你看这个原生，就即使是阶段性的原生产品
就说比如说第二阶段最好的东西，一定是口碑的
因为它一定是在体验上有大突破的
就像龙虾也是自己爆的嘛，就没有人
是在体验上有大突破的，就像龙虾也是自己爆的嘛
就没有人去做投放啊什么
嗯
然后雅虎也是一样的，就是口碑相传
跨一下就火了，对吧
我93年在这个 UIUC 读书
就是浏览器诞生的地方，所以我可能是全世界最早用浏览器的一
万人之一
那整个校园都疯了，天天晚上不睡觉
就是在用浏览器看各种各样的能看到的东西
然后马上大家就会觉得网上能看到的东西怎么这么少
然后就会有人意识到，哦，做个网站上传上去
肯定是最有意思的事情
嗯
然后马上又会有人发现，这个原来是一个商业的机会
我能赚钱，这个飞轮就转起来了
所以您在这个 Open Cloud 的这个时刻
感受到了92年、93年浏览器爆发的那个时刻那种同样的感受
是
让大家装不上 Open Cloud 都感觉非常焦虑
是的，是的
就要被时代淘汰了
对对对对对对对
刚才说的是这个数据飞轮，那网络效应呢
在 AI 时代，网络效应会什么样
第一个就是网络效应会继续存在，啊
它是就像基础设施一样，它是就像基础设施一样
它成了这个时代的一个标配了，啊
因为最后还是要广泛连接的，就从即使从数据的本质来说
越多元化的数据，越差异化的数据
越能产生新的洞察
就你同样类型的数据，其实规模到了一定的程度
其实它的价值是边际效应递减的，啊
然后第2个呢，就我觉得网络效应的升级版其实是黑洞效应
黑洞效应其实就是应用场景越多，你的连接越复杂
你就更有可能去拓宽你的智商
所以我觉得黑洞效应某种意义上是 AI 时代的网络效应的升
级版
嗯
其实我在《智能商业》这本书里面讲过 DNA 螺旋的两个组
成，一个是数据智能，一个是网络协同
其实黑黑洞效应相当于这两个都升级了
就是数据智能，其实现在 AI 还是数据智能
啊，然后它并没进入所谓符号的 AI 智能
啊，然后它并没进入所谓符号的 AI 智能的这个阶段
我们还是在这个数据智能阶段
然后网络协同实际上是变成了这个黑洞的一种内部的网络结构
它能够快速的去吞噬多少场景，对吧
而不是我们原来的那种简单的连接
新的时代还会出现平台吗
肯定会啊，入口就是平台啊
因为我觉得上一代的平台很多都是因为就是我们的信息效率不够
高，所以它需要一个平台来，呃，让信息效率进一步的流转
我们在今天我们可以用判断力代替信息的不对称啊
但是判断力也是个稀缺资源
嗯
所以就刚才讲到的，一样会出现一个双边市场
就是海量的 agent 的开发商跟海量用户之间怎么完成这
个匹配
就我们看一个网站很容易判断它好是坏
成本不高，不好就不再看
网站很容易判断它好是坏，成本不高
不好就不再看了嘛
但是你用一个 agent 的，有可能出现很大的负面影响的
所以我们判断 agent 的能力的能力要求是更高的
所以在这个阶段，我们大概率会让渡这种判断力给一个独立第三
方，我们认为是信任的
而这个就其实就是一个典型的双边市场的结构
这双边市场是有中等程度的网络效应的
那新的平台和旧的平台，它可能不一样的地方是什么
旧的平台能变成新的平台吗
它能演化过来吗
大概率不能，就是因为旧的平台做的是简单的信息匹配
新的平台要做的是能力的能力跟需求的匹配
嗯
所以复杂度高了很多
就它两边的东西其实发生了变化
是的，是的，是新物种的匹配
虽然还是匹配，但是匹配的东西是不一样的
所以大概率会诞生新的公司
是的，因为你如果不是 agent 的原生的话
你怎么能判断得了 agent 的原生的话
你怎么能判断得了 agent
怎么能够给 agent 提供一个最好的一个通用的开发平台
对吧
但是现在是不是走到平台这一步还有点远
可能还要几年时间
大概就是35年的时间吧
今年大家也在谈，呃，gentle OS
首先，什么是 gentle OS
你有一个定义吗
我觉得没有人能定义得了，gentle OS 我把它放在第
三阶段，所以我们可以基于它去讨论一下
因为你是 OS 就开始调度资源了嘛
就是它就不再做匹配了，就是你只要告诉他一个意图
我就直接调用市场上所有的 agent
直接帮你给活干给干完了
你都见不到那个 agent
那首先 agent 得爆发，真正的爆发出来
是的，所以一定要经历第二阶段这个时间
对的，对，所以只有到一个足够复杂的阶段
你才需要直接去调度 agent
然后 agent 也得成熟到那个阶段才能被简单的调用
所以 gentle OS 比我们想的可能要远
我个人
的调用，所以 Agent OS 比我们想的可能要远
我个人觉得是第三阶段的事情，是比较远的
但是大家在因为在第二阶段就容易去畅想第三阶段可能是什么
所以这个讨论是有意义的
嗯
但是它大概率是没法落地的这个阶段
那您构想中的 Agent OS 可能是什么样的
然后它的话语权有可能被谁争夺到
有可能是模芯公司嘛
有可能是应用公司、互联网公司、算力公司
还是像苹果这样的软硬一体的公司
你照我的理论框架的话，肯定是一个谁都不知道的啥
长啥样的公司，啊，这才叫大创新嘛
要不然它不抵消它未来的那个价值
所以，因为因为就是说，就 Agent 长成啥样
咱们现在都不知道，对吧
然后你再到第二阶段，Agent 的原生硬件是长啥样
我们也不知道
所以得这两个东西得都足够的探索到一定的阶段
我们大概才会找到一个最自然的跟 AI 互动的方式
找到一个最自然的，跟 AI 互动的方式
然后那个 AI 真的能够给我们提供现在想象不到的便利性
啊，那个就是未来的科幻了
那个可以去问科幻小说家，他觉得那个时候会是什么样的一个状
态
哎，这个很有趣啊，就是我们大概基于历史
可能有三步的推演
对
但是每一部它具体 agent 长什么样
agent 的生态长什么样，然后下一步 agent 呃
agent OS 长什么样，原生应用长什么样
其实都是问号
是的
嗯
对
主要，但是讨论第三阶段的好处是
你大概知道最终的终局大概是哪个方向
所以你做第二阶段的时候会更有针对性
然后在第二阶段的中后期，大家的有一部分人的注意力就会开始
走向第三阶段了
但是啊，今年这个 agent 应用公司都很惨淡
可以说是到了近两年来 agent 应用的冰点
去年大家投资应用公司的热情还挺高的
但是今年大家觉得哦，那不就是模型的一个 skill 吗
那应用公司都很难融资了
呃，您觉得这个
一个 CEO 嘛，那应用公司都很难融资了
呃，您觉得这个现象会是短暂的还是长期的
您有什么想对这个应用公司的 CEO 说的吗
我觉得现在是应用领域里面创业者的反共识阶段
就是因为没有没有一个好的应用让大家看到它有多大的潜力
以及它该怎么做，所以大家都在摸索
都在摸索
就比如说，就视频生成这个是已经相对成熟的这个这个领域
然后做 AG 的公司也很多啊，然后大家最终的目标可能都要
做 AI 时代的 TikTok
对吧
这抖音啊这些，但是大家都知道离的现在很远
那你第一步到底做啥
这个就非常考验大家的这个啊功力
然后 AI 短剧动漫这个呢又有点门槛太低
所以很快的半年大家就都干完了
嗯
就而且是 AI 模型能力顶上
大家就都干完了，嗯，就而且是 AI 模型能力顶上来以后
基本上就干完了，所以所以就正好我们处在一个青黄不接的时候
就模型的能力已经溢出到很多简单的任务
它自己就能干了
但是呢，我们又没有找到一个足够大的场景
可以用 Agent 的方法去真正让 AI 做一个足够复杂
又足够有价值的事情，然后还能把性价比非常好的智能用的很充
分的，然后又能形成自己的独特技术积累的
所以就是大部分人其实低估了 Agent 的难度
就去年大家有点像，我当时的感觉就像小孩过家家一样的
就啊我有个新玩具，有好多好玩的事情
然后大家就开始下场玩各种各样的东西
都没觉得它那个东西能做多大，因为大家那时候考核考核标准也
很很简单，你只要有 AR 就好
那 AR 嘛，你一个新技术当然是有价值的
总有人愿意付费，然后大家又有一个好的 AR
觉得大家都很开心，就是所以
一个好的呀，觉得大家都很开心，就是所以我我这个到去年年底
在整个硅谷的感受，就像着一个创业的天堂
就是说所有的人都在那玩的很嗨
但是今年就是说 OK，就是模型的能力有一个大的突破
然后原来的那批过家家的小孩子就被淹没了
那，然后但是今年也许智能，就我听到那个普遍的感受
就是大家都觉得智能是真的能干活了
可以信赖了，因为推理能力达到了一定的水平嘛
然后开始真有人想，我能不能严肃的拿它干点重要的活
这才是应用阶段开始的真实的标志
所以模型公司会吞噬一切吗
您肯定也听到这个说法了吧
在今年，模型吞噬一切
没有模模型吞噬一切的前提是，所有的东西都在模型射程内
按现在的范式发展的模型，它肯定会有一个阶段性的发展阶段
智能够用了，智能够用了
然后这个阶段，就会有一堆的新的技术要求出来
去做不同场景下的东西
那你模型就不可能吞噬掉所有的一切啊
就我我举个特别直观的例子，就是这一个很好用很好的例子
就是1892年，爱迪生发明电灯泡
照亮了曼哈顿的一公里的范围内的这个平方公里范围内的这个地
这个大家都知道啊
然后1910年，有一个实质性的突破
就美国大概就就大概在那之后就开始有了发电厂、电网的概念啊
大概1910年，大概电网覆盖了美国可能主要的城市
然后在那一年，终于出现了两个大应用
1910年才出现了两个大应用啊
除了照明啊，电灯照明那是第一个大应用
嗯
家里头真正出现 TOC 的两个大应用
洗衣机跟电冰箱，一直到10年出现
它还使用了电
对，还有一个很重要的，收音机
嗯
收音机，然后我们第3个离不开的家用电器
实际上到1925年才出现
那个是空调
这空调肯定离不开了
这今今年这个欧洲的这个酷暑，已经让很多人意识到空调的重要
性
到今天都离不开空调
30年才出现电视机
所以应用的发展，它肯定是有它的规律的
然后我们今天离不开洗衣机、电冰箱跟空调
但是收音机跟这个电视机，被压缩到了手机里面
这两个就基本上没有了
电视机就稍微还有一点点存在感，但是基本上被电脑跟手机给取
代了
所以我想讲的就是说，这个就就就讲公司层面一个很有意思的选
择啊
就爱迪生发明了电，但是
一个很有意思的选择啊，就爱迪生发明了电
但是他认为发电更重要，所以他成立了通用电气公司
最早是做发电设备的，但是他没有意识到电网非常重要
所以他的助理离开了，成立了美国第一家这个送电公司
嗯
啊，那但是通用电器真正成功是因为它生产出了最早的电冰箱跟
洗衣机
哦，这个很有意思
对
所以它其实是因为一个 To C 的应用突破了以后
然后电网就成了基础设施
嗯
成了一个 To B 的服务的一个基础设施
就大家不再关心电网的公司的品牌了
但是通用电器繁荣了60年，然后就把各种各样的应用就一步步
做出来了
嗯，哎，不过刚才说的是硬件的 To C 的产品
那时候没有软件，因为那时候没有知识
没有数字化的信息啊
哦，直到互联网这个时代
不是，那时候也开始积累了，但是那个积累是很浅的
IBM 成立于1910年
嗯
是因为开始有了这些设备，然后要开始处理数据
现代化的工厂出现
是有了这些设备，然后要开始处理数据
现代化的工厂出现了，所以才要能去管理信息
但是 IBM 真正大发展是计算机出现以后才开始
嗯，所以要看在智能时代，是能更好的利用智能
做出一个 To C 的，不管 To C 还是 To B
的这样的产品，也不管是硬件还是软件
是的
你看现在的应用公司做着做着，就会开始要去训模型了
因为他们觉得如果没有自己的模型
可能跟模型公司竞争起来没有竞争力
比如说 Curacy，那您觉得应用公司应该训自己的模型吗
我还是澄清一下概念，就是我觉得我们还是把 Agent 或
者智能体当做新时代的主体，嗯，创业的关键啊
他们跟模型之间的边界会逐渐的清晰
啊，然后我刚才也讲到了，Agent 公司的技术创新可能也
是非常大的，只是它不一定跟现在大模型技术创新的轨迹是一样
的，啊，然后同时呢，因为大模型之间的竞争关系会让大模型能
提供的能力成为一个大众商品基础设施
所以做智能体的公司其实没必要再开发这样的大模型了
然后呢，科舍呢不是我们定义的这样的主体
它只是当时在 coding 能力不够的情况下
它在去试模型能力的边界在哪
嗯
所以当模型发展以后，它其实被 fold into
就被包进去了，成了模型迭代的一个养料
所以这是两个完全不同的阶段
就是，所以为什么过去两年不太容易找到那个规律
是因为它这些东西都在动态发展
但是当你理解了基础设施跟这个呃 agent 的这个发展的
一个根本的差别以后，就你现在问 agent 的人
他们可能会认为自己将来的技现在问 agent 的人
他们可能会认为自己将来的技术，应该跟大模型的技术是有一个
比较清晰的边界
所以 agent 的公司不用自己训模型
对吧
呃，不用训传统意义上的模型
嗯
因为你可以稳定的调用，不用担心模型公司切断你
因为有一个合理的替代品，随时可以接上来
Minus 需要自己训模型吗
Minus 看他接下来想训什么样的模型了
因为就是你做 agent，你也要做很大的技术投入的
所以 minus 正好卡在那中间
他得去探索那个边界在哪
嗯，但这个可能都是我们阶段性遇到的一些问题
就是模型公司要怎么做，应用啊，应用公司要怎么做模型
慢慢的产业的生态可能会更加的清晰化
是的
嗯
就是开始有几个像样的 to C 的 agent 开始跑起
来以后，大家大概就有感觉了
为什么 Open Cloud 这个火热一下
热情就下去了
没有啊，就是第一个，它是一个小众的用户啊
就下去了，没有啊，就是第一个，它是一个小众的用户啊
就毕竟还是极客跟 CU 最感兴趣嘛
它并没有扩大到大大众，对吧
第2个呢，现在技术的确不成熟，所以大部分 CU 就都是敢
于尝试的 CU 都被折腾的痛不欲生
就真正能够把龙虾刨起来的没几个人
所以就说它是做了一次很好的演练
让大家看到了潜力和方向
但是那个产品本身就是一个早期的
就是我们讲那个企业发展周期，或者说那个啊这个创新扩展周期
它就是最早极客尝试一下的那个实验产品
到今天，可不可以说一个非常好的 To C 应用
To C agent 还没有出现
在今天这个阶段，我有限的范围内没有看到
嗯，但是它会出现，也没有大家想那么悲观
是吧
没有，没有，这我非常乐观，一定会出现啊
其他人很悲观吗
今天都到了历史低点，没有，那是因为从投资人
今天都到了历史低点了
没有，那是因为从投资人的角度来说
他现在因为上一轮受了伤，然后这轮又没看到像样的
他可能不想看了而已
你想看，如果没有一个 to c 的好的应用
我们要 ai 干嘛
有没有可能应用最后其实就是几个模型公司做的
最大的机会
有可能 open ai，open ai 一直就想做啊
对呀，对吧
但能不能做到，那就看它的组织能力
它的创新能力
所以模型公司一定会想做，也一定会做
问题是它最后能不能成，那是另外一回事情
嗯，你有什么想对应用公司的 ceo 说的吗
现在苦苦挣扎的应用公司的 ceo
其实就是找到自己发展的方向，认真做好自己的事情就好
但是融资是个很现实的问题，这个我也理解
这没办法
这个你早期你做一件全新的事情，早期就是比较困难
2026年其实还有一个现象，除了这波应用公司出现了好多应
用 labs，不管是在美国还是在中国
对
呃，他们的方向可能有 af，ai
有视觉模
还是在中国，对，呃，他们的方向可能有 AFAI
有世界模型，这几个是比较多的
您怎么看这个 New Labs 背后涌现的根本的原因啊
为什么会出现这个现象
为什么需要探索新的模型范式
我觉得可能几个方面吧
一部分人可能是看到了现有范式的一个天花板
或者他从原理上，像元老困难一样
他从原理上就认为这个事情是有偏差的
或者说它的天花板是很很有限的
嗯
那他终于有了机会去试一下自己一直就有的想法
所以这是一类啊
那一类的确是觉得可能就要 Scaling Law
它有个边际递减的一个一个趋势，就不管它现在发展多好
那早晚会有个趋势
这个可能也是部分人的共识，所以大家才会一起都出来嘛
第3个呢，我觉得反而是因为大模型的基础能力到了一定的程度
大家可以去尝试一些跟现有大模型技术路径不太一样
但是也非常底层的一些一些创新，比如说像 AF 上
也非常底层的一些一些创新，比如说像 AI for Sci
ence，嗯，那个就是类似这样的难度
而且也需要大模型的支持，但是做的事情可能跟现在的大模型技
术路径不太一样，所以这一几大类都被统称为了 new la
b
New labs 会成为一个过渡型的现象
还是会成为一个长期的组织形态啊
我觉得他们是新的组织形态的早期的雏形
新的组织形态的早期雏形，嗯，那还是会长期存在
对吧
会，它会继续演化，因为就是说，你看大家为什么会叫 new
lab，就是因为不满意公司嘛
就公司要被淘汰了嘛，对吧
哎，会吗
呃，肯定的，因为因为公司跟工业时代是一起产生的
啊，工业时代之前是没有公司的，只有手工作坊
所以工业时代最大的一个制度创新
就是终于有了公司这种组织形式，嗯
然后让现代
公司这种组织形式，嗯，然后让现代化管理可以被这个运营起来
才能支撑公司的规模化扩张
所以这它是一个配套的制度
如果工业时代的这个很多的基本经济规律被挑战了
它的组织形态肯定也会被挑战
所以呢，大家更愿意叫 lab，对吧
但是 lab 呢，这个呢，我为什么说它是雏形呢
是因为它更加像这批研究员在一起工作的状态
对
但是它要变成未来普通人可能也是用这种类似跟更加要原始的方
式工作，所以它会有一些新的演化
就真正的第一个 new lab 是OpenAI
或者说叫 Anthropic
所以这一批企业其实应该叫 new new lab
因为他们还是借用了 new lab 这种组织形式
但是它开始做不同的事情
new lab 的本质应该是 lab
不是公司了
对
你觉得这个未来会成为一个常态
未来我们叫那个组织叫
这个未来会成为一个常态
未来我们叫那个组织叫什么名字
我觉得现在不确定，大概率也不会叫 lab
就就是你看我这本书里面，我刻意从头到尾都在讲组织
我特意不用“公司”这个词，就是因为我觉得就就就包括今年大
家都在谈 AI 原生组织，为什么用这么复杂的这3个词
就是因为不知道这个词还没有被定义出来
这个组织形态也在刚刚的孕育期，可能5年以后我们会有个新词
叫这个新组织形态，但是今天我们没有
所以大家叫 AI 原生组织，简称 New Lab
所以您觉得公司作为工业化革命的产物
它有可能会消失
科层制管理的这种公司制度会衰亡
会衰亡
是的
但是人类的分工协作会继续，组织永远会存在
因为有人的地方就有组织，但是组织用哪种形态
有人的地方就有组织，但是组织用哪种形态
这个是个历史演化的过程
为什么 AI 革命会带来的变化如此剧烈
剧烈到就感觉已经伤筋动骨了，连组织这种形态都已经从公司开
始向其他的方向开始转变
为什么就是变化这么大呀
你讲两个类比就能理解嘛
第一个，至少把它类比为工业革命
对吧
那工业革命基本上颠覆掉了以前所有的农业时代的那些东西
那么 AI 如果是超越工业革命的这样的技术创新的话
那工业时代的大部分东西也会被淘汰掉
第2个，你从一个更底层的角度来说
人类一直是很自豪自己是地球上唯一的智能动物
然后其典型标志是因为我们有语言会说话
那 AI 也能说话，AI 能理解人的所有的知识
AI 也具备了智能
AI 能理解人的所有的知识，AI 也具备了智能
所以从这个角度来说，我们未来的世界发生的变化是超出我们想
象的
所以过去的很多我们习以为常的事情
在20年以后完全可能会不存在，这个应该是大概率的事情
AI 原生组织应该怎么搭建
哦，这是一个特别大的话题了
我们讲个最底层的逻辑吧，岗位可能就不存在了
或者说岗位是公司最基本的一个运行单元
所以我们应聘都是应聘一个岗位，对吧
公司发展要发展了，先要定一个岗位
给一个工作描述，然后去招人，然后这个公司才能发展嘛
对吧
然后因为有岗位，所以有汇报线，啊
有层级，有相应的报酬，所有的东西都跟岗位连在一起的
那岗位是现在组织的一个基本单元
但是 AI 时代组织的基本单元
但是 AI 时代组织的基本单元是任务
是什么是要被解决的事情，所以大家是围绕着任务在流转的
这个组织肯定就完全不一样了
那如果从岗位变成任务，人应该怎么在这个组织里结构起来呢
这就是现在大家都在探索的最有意思的问题
这个问题问的非常的好，所以阶段性的产品是大家讲的 AI
一定要嵌入工作流，但这个只是阶段性产品
因为那个工作流是为人设计的
对这个还是感觉是现有的公司和组织加 AI
对，所以 AI 原生的组织会从第一天开始就去定义那个任务
然后去拆解那个任务，再去分配那个任务
所有的人和 AI 都是围绕这个任务
归集员工和探集员工都是围绕着任务的流转在协同的
这超出大部分人的想象，这需要点时间去消化
但是就是它是一个任务分解跟完成
但是就是它是一个任务分解跟完成的
那以后找工作找什么的
没有一个岗位了，你去认领任务啊
现在就就这几个大 lab，都是在就任务发布
然后你去认领啊，你觉得你能干你就接啊
然后你能 deliver 结果
你的东西就上线了，嗯，呃，就公司只要发布任务
你只要去认领任务就行了
它是一个更加网状的一个结构，是的
是的，它的层级会进一步减少，不存在了
不存在了，因为层级存在是因为不知道谁说了算嘛
嗯，那就先定个层级，层级高的人说了算嘛
嗯，它不是以判断力为标准的，当然这个层级本身跟判断力的级
别有关啊，但它原则上就在任何一个特定场合是谁级别高谁说了
算嘛，但未来是谁的能力强，谁被调用嘛
那这个基层、中层、高层这种结构也就没了
岗位中层、高层、低层都是叫为什么叫科层制管理
它其实就是有这样的垂直
科层制管理，它其实就是有这样的垂直的分工的
嗯，有这个命令线的，嗯，所以当这个命令线被打破以后
将来的协同就不是靠命令的，所以传统意义上的中层肯定是消亡
了
怎么激励员工呢
因为设置这种层级，它有一部分的原因也是作为一个激励线
让你爬格子嘛，在这个组织里
对啊
那以后的绩效考评和人的这个驱动力来自于哪里
在一个组织里
本质上是自驱啊
嗯
就为什么这半年硅谷最流行的一个词叫“high agenc
y”，对吧
就是我们讲主观能能动性嘛，你自己掌握自己的命运了
你有没有成长
没有人比你更了解的，对吧
所以你成长了，你开心了，你就继续做；你没成长
不开心，你去换个地方呗
而且你的竞争对象似乎也不只是你的同事们
也包括你的 AI 同事们
是啊，第一个非常重要的，的确是更加向内看
就是你自己得找到
第一个非常重要的，的确是更加向内看
就是你自己得找到你的驱动力
第2个呢，你要有为什么叫主观能动性呢
你要明白你要培养什么样的能力
嗯
第3个呢，你要找到这个能力最适合应用的场景
然后跟着这个场景一起去成长
第5个呢，因为你承担了这个，因为你接了这个任务
你交了结果，这个东西是非常透明的
所以你一定会得到相应的奖励
但为什么这些 Top Research 转会费那么高呢
是因为贡献很透明啊
你看你们采访的时候，我看现在打抬头都叫顶尖研究员
那也没有抬头啊，连 VP 之类的都不写了呀
这个不需要大家也都知道他们的江湖地位
嗯
是因为整个的这个网络更加透明了
就是说谁在做贡献，谁不在做贡献
很清楚，对吧
嗯
这两家公司都有前30个人，前300个人
前1000个人，你再不在那里头
就都很知道
所以 New Lab 它不能算是一个阶段性的产
知道，所以 new lab 它不能算是一个阶段性的产物
它可能算是一个新的时代的，一个组织的早期形态
对啊，因为之所以叫 lab，是因为现在主要的员工是研究员
研究员最能理解的就是一个 lab
他们不喜欢公司，也不喜欢大学，但是他们喜欢 lab
所以就叫 new lab
但是将来其实所有有创造力的人都会在这样现代的新型组织里面
存在，那个时候可能大家就不会局限于 lab 这样一个称呼
了
但也可能不叫公司
肯定不叫公司
肯定不叫公司，所以公司会消失，会公司会消亡
这这没有什么可以遗憾的呀
就将来有更好玩的，你说多少人现在去公司上班是开心的
呃，不开心
对啊，对啊，那你将来可以有更开心的方法
那不就是技术进步给人类带来的价值吗
一人公司会成为一个发展的方向吗
不会啊，为什么一人公司只是
为一个发展的方向吗
不会啊
为什么一人公司只是说公司的很多职能坍塌到一个人身上了
就一个人现在能干原来几十个人能干的活
但是一个人能干的活永远是有限的
所以你一定要有组织啊，一定会有分工啊
一定会有合作，所以一定会有组织啊
所以一人公司是个阶段性的产物，它只是让大家理解了一个人由
于有了 AI 的帮助，它其实能够干原来一个公司花了那么大
的管理跟协调成本才能干到的事情
所以将来的每个人就是一个一人公司
你就这个六边形战士，然后你在那个组织里面再去跟其他的六边
形战士一起去合作
那要产生新的这么多的，就是组织形态
那传统的公司怎么办呢
他们怎么办呢
他们这个公司已经形成了，转型啊
升级啊，成为新物种了
怎么转
不换脑袋就换人啊
不换脑袋就换人
对啊，就是自己的认知需要升级嘛
所以为什么现在在讲 AI 原生的这个认知和理念是有价值的
是因为你得理解新物种会长成啥样
你至少要理解你要跨过的那个鸿沟有多大
你才会去努力
要不然大部分人顺着惯性就是 AI 加
一路加下去了
但是原生的公司争起来的时候，你就会很绝望
嗯，只不过是这个转型的确非常困难
就是因为它本身是反人性的
我原来理解就是这这波 New Lab 其实还是在做早期探
索的时候的一些形态，但是也许可能未来到应用公司
它这种早期形态也是有借鉴价值的
现在的 New Lab 的确都在做早期探索的工作
而且是偏技术型的，所以他们被叫为 New Lab 是非常
自然的
但是未来的公司也是在做非常有挑战的探索型的事情
只是技术只是其中的一个环节，甚至不是最主要的那个驱动环节
嗯
所以那个组织该怎么叫
他们喜欢什么样的一个类比
club，或者是什么
现在喜欢大，大家其实喜欢的是球队的感觉
啊，这个是一个专业的球队
对，如果你是一个 N，NBA 的明星球队
是其中那个明星球员，那肯定就是最大的成就嘛
嗯
我觉得这批人可能会找到一个新的方法来叫他们自己
这些 new lab 的，它可能 AI 协作的方式可能会
延续下去
对，嗯，对
现在这些 new lab 有泡沫吗
大概率有吧
但是泡沫是好事啊
就是说，早期的泡沫肯定是好事，因为重赏之下才有勇夫嘛
对吧
而且大家是都看到类似的机会，这就是市场机制的价值
就是说，因为你你不知道，你事先是没有一个上帝的视角知道
你事先是没有一个上帝的视角知道谁对谁错的
所以你只能是让大家去试错，然后市场就是说
OK，我知道这是方向，所以我愿意投入这么大的资源支持大家
试错，然后这一轮 New Life 之所以这么值钱
或者说可以这么高的估值开始，是因为大家认为他们至少起步是
OpenAI 跟Anthropic
那当你的潜在的回报是这么高的时候
那你当下愿意下的赌注赌注肯定就更高啊
那以您认为 OpenAI Anthropic 只是一个基
础设施提供商的这个角度来说，那 New Life 是不是
不应该值这么多钱呢
没有啊，一样啊，因为你依然得到了一个在10年内从零到了一
万亿的公司啊，那个回报是无比巨大的
嗯，对啊，所以从投资人的角度来说
他们只关心 OpenAI 跟Anthropic 未来3年
从一亿多到至少3亿吧，或者最好要5亿吧
要不然他们投资连风险的这个把锁
或者最好要5亿吧，要不然他们投资连风险的这个 buffe
r 都没有了，对吧
但是投 new lab 的人更多是希望其中的某一家有机会
最终成为下一个 OpenAI、Google、 OpenA
I
因为您这个这本书也是把组织问题放在战略问题之前
首先为什么呀
就是为什么
因为您是一个战略专家嘛
为什么您把组织放在战略之前
理论上不是应该先有了战略，然后我们再定组织吗
过去我们都是这么做的
还是回到那个基本判断，就是呃虽然这个词有点熟
但是我觉得还是要讲，就是说 AI 对于工业时代是一次范式
革命，所以我们看到的是新物种，新物种的共性重要于单独讨论
其中的一个环节啊
所以呢，就说，所以我我后面这两年为什么对组织看的越来越多
是因为你发现你想要的那种未来的战略的生成方式跟原有的组
织是不匹配的，它只有用新的组织形态才能生成新的战略
这两个是阴阳合合的
那为什么会有新的组织形态
是因为它有一个非常原生的大挑战
是决策的频率越来越高，质量的要求越来越高
所以才会有新的组织形态
嗯
然后新的组织里面最重要的决策就是战略决策
所以这两个东西的确分不开，就是你得一起去摸索
我怎么用新的方法做新的战略，然后这个战略帮助我进入了下个
阶段，我才有机会去尝试更多的组织创新
嗯
以一个 AI native 的公司给它的 CEO 提建议
搭组织最重要的是什么呀
搭一个原生组织，先天有优势，它可以搭这个原生组织
其实还是对 AI 理解的深度够不够
就你自己够不够
所以你自己够不够远深
就就比如说，我碰到的好几个，在这方面走的足够远的创业者
基本上都自己重写了自己公司内部的运行的体系
而且因为他们编程能力这么强，AI 帮助这么大嘛
基本上都是李志飞讲的
我把自己关在家里3天，我基本上就把那个框架写出来了
基本上是类似的故事，就是说，因为他们对于那个组织运行的原
型是有深刻的理解的
然后 AI 最大的帮助就是能够快速帮你把原型给实现了
所以他们基本上自己都做了一套体系
但是可能大部分人今天会满足于飞书的 AI 升级
觉得那个就已经够我用了
而且因为我原来已经在飞书上了，所以我的迁移成本也高
但我自己也做不出一个啥新东西出来
然后我要判断别人做的东西靠不靠谱
我大概也没那个能力
所以这
别人做的东西靠不靠谱
我大概也没那个能力，所以这个中间大概就成了一个分水岭
就是未来真正 AI 原生组织的人
最早一批 CEO 大概是自己动手
重新写了自己的组织运行方式的，因为那个就是未来的组织的神
经网络啊，就它的神经网络是怎么连接在一起的
嗯
而且我们讲工作流啊这些，其实都跟神经网络啊这些它的类比本
质上是一致的
你原来的 ERP 就是一个固化的道路
固化的道路它就一定有各方面的僵化跟局限
它就不可能是一个实时反应的网络
对吧
但是神经网络的适应能力是远远超过任何东西的
神经网络的天然就是对应的任务
那对于现在就是已经有公司的 CEO 有什么建议
如果你想继续在最前沿参与竞争的话
你的确就得在 AI 原生方面做更大的努力
当然竞争都是相对的，就是说
面做更大的努力
当然竞争都是相对的，就是说如果你是跟兔子比赛跑
那你的速度要求跟你去跟猎豹比赛跑
那肯定速度要求是不一样的
所以谈战略之前要先谈组织，组织对于 CEO 来说变得更重
要了
呃，其实是阴阳两面，就没办法完全剥离开的
因为都是基于同样的新的 DNA 长出来的东西
所以还是我刚才讲到的，就是说我讲战略一定会讲到组织
就比如说聊着聊着我就问一下，哎
你们公司到底有多少人
呃，现在谁参与战略讨论
嗯，对吧
这个就进入了组织的部分
那你聊组织的时候肯定会问，那你现在组织面临最大挑战是啥
那你的组织是为了解决这个问题的
那你这个组织有没有机会解这个问题
对吧
所以这两个东西是结合的非常紧密的
对未来这个组织的构想，您觉得可能和现在的组织这种公司的形
态不同或者什么
除了它的呃中心从以岗位为中心变成以任务为中心
还有其他的不同点吗
呃，中心从以岗位为中心变成以任务为中心
可能人会变得更少
人变得更少是肯定的，或者阶段性的变得更少是肯定的
将来说不定有太多好玩的东西，大家可以一起玩
那是另外一个、那第三阶段的事情
我们只讲第二阶段
嗯
就第二阶段是因为 AI 杠杆作用足够大
然后呢，对人的要求又相对比较高
所以能够适应这个新组织的，刚开始是相对少部分
就说非常积极主动、愿意尝试新东西
然后学习能力非常强的人，啊，所以他们会摸索出一套跟 AI
协同的方法
然后这套协同方法摸索出来以后，也许可以开放
吸引更多的人可以用相对更简单的方法参与进去
太有意思了，我感觉这个处在智能革命的开端
就是你可以尽量把它往大了想，而不是往小了想
不要想只是一个互联网的变化，要想的可能比工业革命更大的一
个变化
是的
所以未来可能比工业革命更大的一个变化
是的，所以未来可能是翻天地覆的一个变化
是的，而且，一切刚刚开始，而且接下来的想象力是属于所有人
因为第一个阶段，就是说，你看所有的团队创业者都是以研究
员跟技术专家为核心的，嗯，是因为他要做早期的特别大的技术
突破，但是当技术成为基础设施以后
各种各样的产品、运营、跟用户的连接、同理心这些东西就变得
非常重要了
嗯，我看到您书里对研究员为什么值这么多钱
给了一部分合理化的解释，因为他是跟 AI 交互最多的人
他最能理解 AI 的边界在哪里
他能够跟 AI 最好的互动
现在他们就是创造最大价值的人，然后现在市场又比以前更高效
能够比较快速敏锐的识别出谁是创造最大价值的人
所以他们就获得了市场认为他们就获得了市场认为他们抵制恶物
的这个价格
你觉得产品经理在下一个时代还重要吗
当然重要，就是说或者说产品经理会变得无比重要
是因为你做什么产品，服务什么客户
创造什么价值，用什么技术，这都是你要做的决定
嗯
有限的时间投入在哪一件相对最重要的事情上
这个都是产品经理要去判断的
嗯
只是说今天就我们看到的这些大模型公司
他们因为必须是技术主导，所以你会看到
就是说基本上是研究员主导的
呃，但这中间有个特别有意思的现象
就是我也讲的比较尖锐一点，就是这一批的创业者要过的一个很
大的坎是有没有足够的开放的心态去理解商业世界的运作规律
嗯
就我发现很多的技术人员没法接受
就我发现很多的技术人员没法接受一个简单的事实
就是我的技术这么牛，我创造了这么大的价值
为什么我公司可能不值钱
因为经济学的基本规律，只要有同质化的供给
你就不可能获取高额利润，你就是一家不怎么值钱的公司
所以这个跟技术人员以前的接受的整个的模型训练是完全不一样
的
所以极少数的技术人员必须完成这个蜕变
就作为方的作为 CEO，他必须去理解经济学的基本规律、商
业世界的运行规律，然后他才能够成为一个合格的 CEO
把公司带的足够远
你觉得新时代产品经理或者是方的
他需要是 research 背景吗
他需要是这种技术背景吗
下一代的大概率不需要的
这一代需要对吧
对，就模型这一代是肯定需要的
但是下一代应用驱动就不需要
对
然后你到那个你到聚升这一代，你就已经看得到聚生这一代
你就已经看得到，聚生基本上都是联合创始人
然后基本上一个是大模型背景，一个是偏应用跟商业背景
嗯，是因为他们一开始就碰到了这个问题
哎，对啊，今天好像一个创始团队
他的联合创始人变得比以前多
这也是一个 AI 原生组织的开始越来越显著的特征
因为每个人都必不可缺啊，嗯，要不然就用 A 卷的上了
所以我书里面有一句很重要的判断
就未来，整个企业会越来越像合伙人企业
呃，有一个很有意思的这个这个补充啊
就刚才讲的公司是工业时代啊最大的一个制度创新
然后它取代了原来的手工作坊，但是有一个制度是平行存在的
就是合伙人企业，就像律师事务所啊
大的咨询公司啊，甚至包括投行啊
早期其实都是合伙人企业，合伙人企业的典型特点就是几个人的
分
合伙人企业的典型特点就是几个人的分工合作都很重要
少了谁都不行
所以未来的组织，你会发现全员都是合伙人的这种情况会越来越
普遍
要不然我就不招你，招你其实就是因为你的贡献必不可少
那你其实就是一个合伙人，只不过是可能你早期进来叫联创
后来进来就叫合伙人了
这个可能也会有非常大的变化，就每个人都有的不可替代性
是的，然后呃人数也显著变少
对，我们只要是一个合伙人的组织就可以
就是一个球队
对对
然后每个人的有差异化，不是同质化
每个人也要更强
对呀，那肯定互补啊
如果就是你的覆覆覆盖的话，那就靠呼这个数字分身去做了
多少人是比较合适的
这个跟跟任务有直接的关系
所以就像我们 AI，他们的人数上升也很快
因为它解决的问题是越来越复杂
嗯，这 AI 时代的创业者呈现特征和过去没有别问题是越来
越复杂
嗯，这 AI 时代的创业者呈现的特征和过去没有变化
这个阶段的变化是非常明显的，就是科学家创业嘛
但它不会持续到下个阶段
下个阶段，我觉得科学家创业的比例会大幅下降
您之前也说过，优秀创始人和卓越创始人
您觉得他们这个分界和差异是什么
您能一眼识别哪个是卓越的创始人
哪个是优秀的创始人
识别不出来
就说卓越，为什么说卓越难
卓越，我我讲的最重要的一句话，就卓卓越是事后认定的
是因为你克服了一次一次的负反馈
当所有人都不认可你的时候，你最后会以巨大的成功证明你是时
代最早的那个先知
所以这个卓越的过程是一个逐渐展开的过程
嗯，而优秀是一个持续有正反馈的成长过程
所以这两条路径是完全不一样的
大部分是优秀的人
对，因为优秀跟人的心态是比较匹配的
所以，但是跟卓越同样成比例的
是比较匹配的，所以但是跟卓越同样成比例的就是我开始讲到的
很多人是疯狂的，失败的，就真正卓越的人
就是有疯狂想法的人，能走向卓越的人也是非常非常低的比例的
狂想的人可以很多，也很容易，但是你不但是想对了
还能落实的那个是极为稀缺的能力
而且你问这些人的话，他可能也未必认为自己有什么不同
这就是在那个基业长青那本书里面讲到的
就是他看到的那些特别卓越的企业
他就是另外一本书就叫优秀到卓越嘛
对吧
两本书都是那个都是同一个作者写的
他其实讲你真正问这批人的时候，他们有个极大的特质
都是把成功归于别人，然后都认为自己是因为运气
他是收集了这些人的访谈对外沟通的信息
我觉得一开始听起来哈有点反常识
但你真正去体会的话，应该是那样才有可能
为什么
因为事情大于人啊，因为你一定自我很小才能走那么远啊
是时代成就了你，的确是
你只不过是碰巧，在合适的地方跟合适的人在一起做了合适的事
情
所以如果你只是为了证明自己，证明你有多牛
就是他书里面讲的第四级的领导者
在某一个时间点，世界都会打脸打你的脸来证明你其实没有你想
象的那么厉害
所以自我小一点才有可能
是的
利他、同理心和自我逐渐变小，大概是走向卓越必不可少的因素
因为你 ego 大的话，你会一直想要证明自己
你就会一直在那个正反馈的循环里
是的
所以你大概率走的是一个就是普遍性正确的道路
是的，因为你急着证明自己嘛，所以你需要短期反馈嘛
你是为了自己的 ego 嘛，所以你不会去真真正的去感知和
理解真正的去感知和理解真实的世界
你对信息的处理一开始，就会容易受你先入为主的判断的影响
那如果是另一条路呢
他想的是，我要怎么把这个事情最大化
还是我要把这个事情做好，对吧
就要我愿意听更多的人不同的意见
我相信大家都很优秀，我们是为了成就这个共同的梦想
那整个公司的凝聚力就不一样了，这就是真正意义上的使命驱动
的公司
嗯，所以你如果问我的话呢，我也会把公司分成4个层级：啊
机会驱动的公司、战略驱动的公司、远见驱动的公司、使命驱动
的公司
但是这个使命是发自内心的，你真心 believe 的
你完全信就要相信跟拥抱的，不是你编出来写在墙上激励别人的
嗯，那样那样的人是非常非常少的
怎么辨别它是一个使命还是战略
你这可能只有你自己知道，可能只有你自己知道
可能自己都不知道
经常有创业者过来跟我讨论战略问题
我其实经常问的第一句话，往往把他们搞懵了
就我经常会问10年以后你会对怎样的自己满意
就这个问题就是最能反映你对自己当下是什么期望
你大概这一段的旅程是什么驱动的
但是这个问题本身也是一个自我异构的问题啊
你有自我异构，你才会想10年后的自己是什么样子
说有的人会讲，哎，我就是对这个事情特别感兴趣
我希望这个事情能成，这种肯定事情就已经大于人了
有的人是说，哎，我就是好奇，那这个也比证明自己要要有意思
然后有的人就会说，我就是要做一个100亿美金的公司
就是付费答案
对，因为这个基本上是自我驱动嘛
就是要一个外部的认可嘛，所以他很多的东西都会基于这个去做
调整跟变化
东西都会基于这个去做调整跟变化
它不是一个内在驱动，它其实是个外部的
它受外部的衡量标准影响很大，所以每一轮的估值就容易对它有
冲击
这都像在交答卷
对呀，对呀
您听过最好的回答是什么
马老师最早创业之前讲的“让天下没有难做的生意”
那个就是他自己发自内心相信的东西
他那是使命还是战略
那是使命
嗯，还有过很好的回答没有
呃，我觉得马斯克去火星也是使命啊
嗯，然后这是一个脱离于我自我的一个事情
对呀，他是要把人类带入外太空时代啊
对创业者来说，哪些是非共识
哪些是噪音啊
怎么辨别
这个跟这个战略制定也也有很重要的关系
就是说，因为你就是在判断嘛，对吧
判断信号跟噪音，一个可能是尽量感知的全面一点
就是真实的去体会外界发生什么变化
第2个呢，就是可能思考要更深入一点
这样的话，你大概能慢慢分清楚噪音跟这个信号
很多人是不太过脑的，就是说思考你不深的话
当下流行什么你就跟着流行去了，所以会很累
因为你一直在追，在追趋势，别人已经领跑两步了
你没看见，你只看见了它冒出水面的第三步
所以你追肯定就是第一天就是输掉的
嗯
那第2个呢，就是有可能你就是因为接触的面太窄了
所以你容易做出一个局部的最优的判断
但你可能失去了一个更大范围内的一个
是这样
对对对对
嗯
这好多都是心法感觉
我个人是比较爱琢磨心法层面的事情
对，而且理论的东西容易反而被大家容易被理论框住
因为你只对那句话就记住了那句话
然后呢，你自己可能依葫芦画瓢，就容易出很多问题
但是新法，如果你掌握了的话，就能够根据具体的情况随机应变
了
因为您也说，就是现在做战略，首先要组织
并且战略也是时时变化
那今天这个战略还重要吗
就是您以前也说过，要看10年、想3年、干一年
这个在 AI 时代还 work 吗
今天战略无比重要啊
你做出一个重要决定，你就出局了
这个淘汰赛是可能以月、以以几个月就就来计划的
嗯
所以，我为什么会讲 AI 时代需要一套新的战略方法论
是因为你持续做出正确战略决定的重要性是非常高的
就越不确定的时候，越需要战略思考能力啊
就越不确定的时候，越需要战略思考能力
啊，如果都很确定的，大拼的就执行能力嘛
对吧
那第2个呢，就是其实看10年、想3年、干一年
就是我对 A
S
的战略方法论的一个比较这个形象化的总结
但是大部分人记住了看10年、干一年
因为那是他们习惯的工业时代的战略方法论
因为工业时代或者说就从90年代开始的这个很多的传统企业的
方法论，是因为这个在一个相对成熟和发展缓慢的世界
看10年是比较清楚的
因为你每年就是5%、8%的增长
然后10年以后大概会变成啥样，也没有新的玩家
所以你大概是知道的
然后在这个情况下，你做今年的规划也很容易
嗯，基本上就是线性推演加一个就线性外推嘛
然后战略如此的不重要，以至于大公司都把战略外包给麦肯锡这
样的咨询公司了
所以80年代开始到00年左右，麦肯锡、BCG 这些公司有
一个井喷式的发展，就是因为这些公司认为战略不重要
都可以外包给别人了
所以呢，这个麦肯锡他们过去就是根据行业经验
根据我们的战略方法论，我帮你制一个制定一个10年的规划
然后你就按年去执行就行了，双方都很 happy
但是我们今天的问题在于，看一年是远远不够的
就你没把线没法线性外推，对吧
线性外推就不可能得出 Ensrupke 今年80倍的同比
增长的收入了
就就是因为你是一个 vision driven 的人
然后你放弃了一个线性外推的思考方式
你才可能有未来
但是由于未来如此不确定，所以看10年帮不了你太多
因为当下从哪下手你还是不知道，所以你得逼着自己去想一个大
概3年左右的一个途径
所以真正的创造力在看3年，看3年要求你大概看个两三步
就我第一个马拉松是什么，第2个里程碑是什么
第3个里程碑可能是什么，然后我今年做的第一个重要的事情是
为了满足哪一个里程碑，所以你就会有短期、中期、长期之间的
一个动态的张力，这个张力引领企业有可能更好的做出当下的战
略选择
所以，就没有这个看3年的这个张力
其实战略就没有发生的那个环境了
就相当于在一个三维空间思考最优解
跟你在一个三维空间思考最优解，跟你在一个二维平面寻一个最
优解完全不是一回事情，啊
这应该以多长周期为频率来思考战略
啊，好问题，所以我说看3年想3年干一年是一个形象化的比喻
它本质是要彰显看3年的创造力以及短期、中期、长期的那个
冲突和矛盾，啊，利益取舍战略本质是关于取舍嘛
最核心的就是这个取舍啊
但是你也可以看5年想两年干半年
这个根据每个行业不同，甚至你可以看3年想一年干一个季度
这个节奏是根据行业发展可以有些不一样的
但是一定要有中期的一个思考，啊
就一定要看到至少三步，而不能只看一步
嗯
所以关键是中间的那个节点
对，就是去年有一个创业公司做 agent 做应用的公司问
我，呃，他他们公司发展很好，AI
做应用的公司问我，他他们的公司发展很好
AR 涨得很快
我就问了他一句话，我说，AR，继续涨两年以后
又怎么样呢
最后产业终局会咋样的
AR 有没有个天花板呢
那个天花板多快会来呢
所以他一下就明白了，他回去后来算了
就是发现天花板不高，就就赶紧回去就是说去做一些新的事情了
对吧
但是当你就是线性的看 AR，VR 每个月都在增长
年增长率多就是多好，特别是 AR 这是个很虚幻的事情
它不但是一个线性外推，而且还是拿当下外推12个月
是很容易让人产生一个增长的幻觉
然后他很可能就突然到顶了，就后面就直线的变成一个线性增长
然后你做的事情其实是一个很不，没有想象空间的事情
对，没有多少价值的事情，所以你短期内的价值模型意义
没有多少价值的事情，所以你短期内的价值模型一出
就是没人愿意付费了
啊，或者是竞争太多了，大家刚开始竞争的时候是按你的创造的
客户价值来定价的，但是当竞争对手一多了
就是按你的边际成本定价的
也是大部分人不理解的一个经济学的基本规律
不管是短期、中期还是长期，我们应该以什么为一个指标呢
就是我们当下能够嗯看自己的成长性的一个标尺
有可能是什么呀
这个指标就是主观的，所以为什么会有 OKR
就是要想解决当你的目标不能转化为 KPI 的数字的时候
大家要用 OKR 的方式协同
只是因为 OKR 落地对组织要求太高了
所以大部分公司或者放弃了，或者 OKR 变成了变形的 K
PI
为什么实际上未来的这个组织，大家现在用“对齐”这个词用的
越来越多，就是很大程度上其实就是对齐
对齐我们的目标，对齐我们对未来的判断
对齐我们背后不同的认知模式，这个是变成了一个更低性的一些
东西
OKR 会延展到 AI 时代吗
我觉得 OKR 的基本理念是对的
但是我们可能会找到，或者说 AI 时代才有可能让 OKR
落地，因为那个组织大脑，那个 AI 的组织的那套的系统
是能够追踪自然语言的表达的
然后它基本上这个神经网络是无无所不在的
所以它大概率有可能给我们一个反馈
说你们都偏离了你们的 OKR
然后我看到了一些更具体的，未必是数字
但是是一些趋势，我可以提醒你们的
所以 OKR 可能真的是需要一套新的方法才能落地
那 AI 时代到底这些公司应该怎么制定战略呢
你们分别说说，模型公司、应用公司、机器人公司
他们分别应该怎么做战略
应用公司、机器人公司，他们分别应该怎么做战略
我觉得那个分不开了，就不同的公司是不同的场景
而且不同的发展阶段
嗯
所以，我我书里面也讲到战略摸索期、战略成型期、战略成熟期
和这个战略执行期
所以你拿行业分，不如拿发展阶段分
对吧
就比如说模大模型公司基本上进入了战略发展期
因为战略都收敛了，大家相对是比较清晰的
但是巨身机器人的公司大部分都在战略摸索期
都不知道该往哪收敛
所以，在这个不同的阶段的战略的方法是是有不一样的地方
但是回到那个更根本的，就 AI 时代的战略生产这个方法跟
以前有什么不一样啊
我觉得最不一样的就以前叫战略规划
现在叫战略生成
我特意创了这个词，因为这个词最本来就反映 AI 时代嘛
大家都习惯了视频生成这个文图生成
而且现在大家说伟大不能被计划
嗯，这个文图生成，而且现在大家说伟大不能被计划
对呀，所以就是真正它其实是生成
啊，所以公司就我们讲组织设计的时候
其实真正要做的是一套体系，一个环境
可以让战略洞察涌现出来
嗯
然后成为一个战略不断生成的系统
最后战略就是一个自然而然的决定
在合适的时间有合适的人做了一个合适的决定
公司就往前走
所以是要把那套生成系统给建起来
那就是组织和环境
对，所以我为什么不得不把组织先说
就是说你如果不理解，因为未来的组织有这个能力做这个事情
它是一个神经网络，它是一个工作流、任务流
它是一个任务流导向的一个系统，然后人跟 AI 都接到这个
系统里面，然后核心是涌现，就跟大模型一样
实际上是人跟 AI 一起在训练一个组织的小模型
嗯
所以核心就是
一个组织的小模型，所以核心就是有没有原来没有想到的洞察可
以涌现出来，整个这个群体智慧有没有在演进
这是最终目标
怎么构建一个好的环境
就除了这个刚刚讲到的类似神经网络这样的系统之外
这就是为什么需要新的文化，需要一个跟全员合伙人能够匹配的
文化
这就为什么 context not control 又重
新火了起来
就5年前，我比如说讲这个 Netflix 案例
甚至讲自己的案例，大部分人觉得挺牛的
但是跟我没啥关系
但是今天所有的人都知道，就是要给 context
给够了 context，它就有那么牛
能做出正确的决策
所以对其是对其目标跟认知，然后就是给够
甚至就是全员共享一个完整的上下文
Long context
对，然后事情就会自然
Long context 对，然后
事情就会自然的涌现
啊，就是人和 AI 都要共享
对，对，因为人没有办法像 AI 那样
有处理全海量信息的能力啊
但是人有瞬间的创造力和看见没有不存在的连接的能力
哎，您觉得今年大家对于就是好多老登的不喜欢
反老登公司，您觉得跟这种 AI 时代带来的这种组织变化、
文化变化的本质是不是也有一些关系
因为可能他们口中的老登是上一个时代公司的这个组织体系、科
层制的体系演化而带来的一些形态遗留下来的
是的，是的，这个特别有意思，这老登这个词特别有意思
就是以前大家都尊老爱幼嘛，对吧
那核心原因是什么
是因为老的经验有价值，老的规范在延续
所以你必须尊老爱幼，这样你才能学到东西嘛
对吧
这才是传承嘛
这样你才能学到东西嘛，对吧
那么为什么用老灯呢
就是你刚刚讲的宏观方面，原来的那套东西
看起来都没什么价值了，是吧
公司受到压力越来越大，谁也不愿意再刻文字
就姚顺宇讲的特别直接嘛，对吧
谁愿意陪老灯玩牺牲自己的这个青春年华
所以这是个非常典型的这个心态
但是在个体上，这个事情能成立的原因
是因为经验相对来说，特别是能够转化成知识的经验
都不再有价值，因为它都被大模型吸收了
所以这些年轻的聪明人用好 AI 杠杆
你瞬间就能成为任何一个领域的专家
啊，所有的这个就是为什么这个 AI 现在也可以达到一个主
任医生的水平
嗯
那是因为所有的经验都被沉淀在大模型里头了
所以你过去20年的经验还有啥价值呢
那年轻人当然就不尊重老年人了
嗯
然后就会有这个相对带点负面的这样的称呼就出来了
那老年人怎么办
或者安心养老，或者变得重新年轻呗
所以，这个新时代的组织它的文化应该是什么样的呢
文化的核心就是，就是创造，就像一个球队一样的
每个人都不可缺少
然后，但是依然有明星、有前锋、有后卫的分工的差别
所以，它的文化一定是开放、透明
然后共享，还有一个非常重要的，我把它叫做共创
嗯
就是说，大家都得明白自己是在共同创造一个新东西
所以，合作跟协同的这种意愿跟能力也会大幅上升
哎，你觉得为什么上一个时代的公司这个体系让人这么不快乐呢
很少有人快乐吧
这没办法，因为大部分的知识工作是简单、枯燥、重复繁琐、没
有成长性的，所以我们自然会觉得那就是一份工作
它是消耗性的，啊，然后既不带来情绪价值
也不带来成长价值
然后公司为了管理，就都是偏控制性的手段
对吧
然后钉又钉的很死，对吧
所以整个的那个环境是越来越不符合今天大家对于文明的向往或
者自我发展的，什么是幸福，什么是快乐的一种理解
所以我我自己是非常乐观的，我觉得 AI 在这个时代给了我
们一个更大的自由度去追求我们想要的那种更好的人生
所以以后的组织可能会更开心一点哈
更有创造力一点
我觉得可能开心就成了必需品了，对
情绪价值是必需品的
那对于创业者的要求也变了呀，是变了
不能是一个那种老板心态，对吧
是变了，不能是一个那种老板心态
对吧
就谁还认你啊，对吧
说我都不陪老登玩了，我还陪你老板玩
对吧
这是完全一个不同的、不同的一个环境了
对
所以你看，现在所有的创业者都讲
他第一优先级就是招人了，嗯
然后招人的时候，都是赶招来的，呃
都不是你说不能 PVA，对啊，咱 PVA 那不认啊
对啊
嗯，服务型自由是
刚才我们聊战略问题，那个地方没有聊完
呃，就是您说像比如说大模型公司它进入战略发展期
然后机器人公司还没有收敛，还是在早期萌芽期
那他们具体来说，他们这个在不同阶段的公司应该怎么制定战略
呢
在战略收敛期的话，就要追求组织效率和执行效率
然后要追求从一个方向型的战略到一个可以闭环的运营模式
所以它才能高效的
因为发展期的核心是规模化，你要上量要快
但是你能够规模化，要上量要快，但是你能够规模化
原因是因为你的核心已经很强壮了
所以它可以被规模化
那么战略探索期的核心是1号位必须带着大家
去做不同的创新，然后要有一套机制
把这个试错的成本给降下来，然后逐步的达成一个共识
所以这个这个阶段你要有自己相信的
但是可能又不能过于执着，因为可能现实会给你打脸
发现别人的方向可能是对的
这个时候就是你，自我能不能让位给
现实，啊，是因为你需要不断的调整
而且每个人的这个出发点，都受制于过去自己的训练
所以你能看到的东西都有路径依赖
所以现在大家一起去创造，那你能不能快速的把别人最好的经验
给，理解、消化、吸收，啊，然后再形成公司下一步的这个创新
的基础
所以呃，在战略这个长时期，核心是创新的效率要足够高
而不是执行的效率
嗯，你看今天大模型公司，不管是美国还是中国
大家都在做，嗯，GPT coding
这好像是一个很大的共识
他们没有非共识是吗
他们应该非共识吗
非共识就是 New Lab，不认这个共识的人就去创业了嘛
嗯
然后 New Lab 里面某一个反共识
可能就会成为3年以后的新共识了
这就是市场特别有趣的地方，它是生生不息的
在这个中间不断的往前演化
现有大不会进入同质化竞争
现在就是同质化竞争，那么就影响它的商业价格
就是你刚才说的那个
所以上个礼拜大家都很恐慌，不就是怕同质化竞争嘛
K 3是吧
对啊，就因为有同质化竞争的这个事情
所以它就打破了对于大模型公司能长期
所以它就打破了对于大模型公司能长期享受高额垄断利润的预期
嗯
然后是因为这个利预期破了，那就才会有大家对于这些公司可能
就没有能力持续去投，还这个高的这个啊 capex
所以源头是前面这些公司还有没有实力
还值不值得为他们继续投入基建
嗯
基建都是为了这些大公司、大大模型公司服务的嘛
如果最后他们创造价值有限，那我干嘛投这些东西呢
您现在的观点是，应该继续投入吗
第一个，我觉得大模型本身发展的空间还非常大
所以大概率基建的投入还会继续，但是可能在某一个时间点会出
现一个拐点，就基建的投入由于周期性会可能超过大模型的真实
的需求
但那件事情从产业发展来说未必是坏事
因为应用公司就可以用很低的成本
是坏事，因为应用公司就可以用很低的成本
去用现有的基础设施，所以他们的进入门槛是大幅降低了的
就是智能的调用真的会变得非常的便宜
又足够的强大和稳定
或者换句话说，只要这个智能的这个供给还没达到大家想要那个
状态，基础设施就会持续投入
所以应用公司可以在苟一苟等一等
哎，你也没法苟一苟等一等，因为你不在这厂里头
你积累不了相应的经验
嗯
等真的大浪来了，你接不住啊
就应用公司还是要有希望，不要那么灰心
哎，对，那那我是觉得绝对要有希望的
嗯
而且他们下场也是因为他们感受到了来自于未来的某些召唤嘛
我们只是在外面可能没有感受到他们那么强烈的这种相信
您觉得机器人公司不管是从模型上还是自身上
呃，因为今天还非常的不收敛嘛
您觉得什么时候可能会出现进一步收敛
它的这个产业周期发展可能会出现进一步收敛
它的这个产业周期发展可能有多长
我刚刚讲了，直接模型公司到 A 证的公司
它的一个阶段嘛，那其实机器人现在是什么阶段
我觉得机器人还在非常早期，就还在摸索到底怎么落地
因为有一些很核心的资源，比如说数据
不像大模型公司原来起来的时候有足够的数据
所以有些很现实的制约，让他们还在一个非常早期的战略探索期
因为现在有好几种做的方法，一种是先从大脑开始做
然后追求这个机器人大脑模型的泛化性；另外一种是从比如说一
个场景开始做，然后做具身、做身体
然后它能在这个场景里通过数据来跑通整个的闭环
然后这个闭环，然后再反补它的模型能力
您觉得应该先突破哪一边呀
我觉得在逻辑上两条路都成立的，就所以你没法事先判断
呃，到底哪条路能赢
嗯
因为泛化的挑战是在于要泛化的空间有多大；第2个
你在一个
的挑战是在于，它泛化的空间有多大
第2个，你在一个具体场景下，特别是一个很大的场景下
你的效果到底够不够好
走这个场景的那些公司呢，它的挑战是在于
现在能找到的场景都不够大
但是呢，它的能力能不能让它快速扩张到一个足够大的场景
既能把能做好，然后又有泛化的可能性
所以原则上就像爬一座山，你可以从南坡爬
可以从北坡爬
事先很难说谁能爬得快一点
机器人这种阶段可以类比为什么产业的什么时期吗
最简单的类比就是他们自己认为的还在两二零二零年左右的阶段
还没到全 GPT 的阶段的大模型公司
哦，能跟更历史的一些什么早期的产业能来做类比吗
车
也可以这么类比，但是车的话呢，前面也是几千家公司
而且它是一个好的类比，就是大概比如说1900年到1920
年，真的有几千家公司在美国都是做车的
有的人觉得，我有一个机械功能，就我能把一个车敲出来
反正马达都是买别人的嘛
嗯
但是后面是出现了一个原生应用，就是福特汽车
1913年，福特，是建了全世界第一条由电驱动的流水线
现代制造业才进入了一个新的阶段
福特才能用极高的效率，生产出一个大众可以消费得起的汽车
所以那是汽车行业的第一个土石业的突破
然后福特就成了现代工业时代的一个代表
但是后面有个很有意思的插曲，就当福特通过规模化标准化
只卖黑色车，做到了全美第一以后
大众的需求开始多元化，然后就出现了通用汽车
有78种车型去竞争的下一个阶段
说明每个战略都要在当时那个时期有效才有效
它不是一个亘古不变的事情
对，现在像大家相当于大家都能手搓一个机器人公司
但是哪个机器人公司能完成规模化量产
谁都不知道
也许我们还在等的那个梯形车阶段
就是在等梯形车阶段，梯形车就很了不起了
你能够规模化量产，这个所以为什么大家都觉得谁第一个真的能
够实打实的把一个一万台机器卖出去
机器人卖出去，就已经是个了不起的成就了
嗯，有没有可能机器人这个产业它可能发展的节奏会更像车去类
比大模型对吗
我在想
你要这么类比的话，我们干脆把它放大到刚才讲到的
就电出现以后，电器的出现，因为基于电可以有 N 种电器
所以你说冰箱跟这个洗衣机谁更重要
就不好比了，大小也差不了多少，对吧
所以我们可能会出现 N 个不同的机器人
真的
我们可能会出现 N 个不同的机器人
真的是是用不同的大场景的
但家用机器人肯定是一个，但家用里头可能也有一个偏陪伴型的
一个偏家务型的
嗯
然后这个这个工业场景或者外面的各种各样的场景
它是一个普在的一个事情
大家为什么这么看好机器人
是因为它是一个 AI 跟物理世界交互的一个基本的界面
嗯
所以就有点像电，什么东西都可以被电再重新干一遍
所以我觉得你你你的问题非常好，就机器人可能更好的类比就是
电器的发展，那个可能是一个更好的类比
然后汽车成了中间的主打，因为 token 类比的是电嘛
对对对对对，汽车的确是其中的主打
但是那个是对外的场景，对内的场景就是洗衣机、冰箱
嗯
对家庭场景
对
在这波巨浪面前，哪些巨头是安全的
我从来觉得在巨浪面前没有人是安全的
谁觉得安全，谁就就谁就是最不安全
谁就就谁就是最不安全的
他们有多不安全
应该都足够的担心吧
他们的战略都是 AFS 的 all in AI 啊
这个够吗
这是必要条件，够不够要看技术演化的路径有多么颠覆
然后新公司获取资源的能力有多大
这主要是看这些方面的挑战
你觉得他们 all in AI 还能够成为下一个时代的企
业吗
就是时代性的企业吗
挑战非常大
挑战非常大，挑战非常大
嗯，从历史里面有依据可言吗
就这个时代企业过渡到下一个时代企业
还能做的非常好的多不多
不是多不多的问题，是有没有的问题
哦，有没有啊
基本没有
哦
IBM 曾经做到过一次，然后微软算是做到过一次
就是微软某种程度上错过了移动互联网
但是它保持住了搜索的火苗，然后有了云计算的极
保持住了搜索的火苗，然后有了云计算的积累
所以加上它在 PC 时代垄断积累下来的 PC 的OS 的
垄断，所以让 AI 时代 Google 起了个大早
对吧
还有一次机会，但是目前看，就微软好像又有点吃不准它到底能
不能走过去了，因为它的模型的投入不够
它模型这块其实已经出局了，对吧
虽然它有 OpenAI 的这个早期的投资
嗯，但是目前它已经买不起 OpenAI 了
对吧
即使算微软这个已经算是维持了很长时间的一个领先的公司
可能未来都不太确定
嗯，Google 呢
Google 就相当于微软的上一段
也许它能成为一个很好的 AI 云公司
但是它能不能成为一个消费者的，大应用
这个还真的不那么确定
入口
对对对
这个还真的不那么确定
入口
对对对，入口级的应用那个不太确定
但是因为它有 TPU，有大模型
有那些，我觉得谷歌作为一个云厂商活下来
这个应该是没问题
哎，所以这种不依赖于你怎么战略选择
你都很难一直在排桌上，是吗
就是这个是让人绝望的地方
这一点都不让人绝望啊，就是人有生老病死
公司也有生老病死，没有比这更正常的了
所以新公司才有机会，年轻人才有才有梦想啊
嗯，这多好的一件事情啊
嗯
对吧
一直都垄断到今天，那不世界太无趣了
谷歌不一定会成为下个时代的谷歌
字节会是下个时代字节吗
同样的，大概率也不会啊
字节今天模型做的也还不错，对吧
起码在国内是第一梯队的
没有啊，所以字节是有很大的机会成为 AI 云公司的
那包括 C 档是做的那么好，在视频生成方面、多模态方面
它都有，它都已经是世界一流的大模型公司
太方面，它都有，它都已经是世界一流的大型公司
嗯，就因为做基础设施是容易的，你有那个积累有沉淀
它有一定的惯性的
但是那个大的 to c 的应用是有非常大的不确定性的
豆包是吗
豆包肯定不是，对吧
要不然它肯定不不计成本的往里砸了
那它不砸了，就是因为豆包不够，不够那么未来啊
豆包更像一个上一代的移动互联网产品
不是，豆包就是第一代 AI 产品
就是那个聊天机器人
豆包没有行动力
智能体的核心是独立完成任务
它把智能体内置进豆包不行吗
这就是他们想做的嘛，就是大家都想做 AI 时代的 OS
嘛
嗯
所以它肯定是想做入口去调度 OS
上一代的入口能不能够理解下一代的整个生态的发展
做成下一代的入口
整个生态的发展，做成下一代的入口
那个挑战是非常大的
因为你如果不是 agent 的事实标准的话
你其实是很难成为入口的
嗯
你调的都是上一代的服务，但你上一代的服务有可能是会被下一
代的服务被，就是他们要被颠覆的嘛
对吧
社交关系会重构吗
腾讯安全吗
肯定重构啊
腾讯作为最安全的，为什么最近这么恐慌
就是因为也有可能不安全啊
肯定重构，社交关系
人跟人的关系都会被重新定义，agent 在里面的重要性也
会大幅上升
所以你不看好这种现有的一个产品
它加 AI 加 agent，你你不看好
我觉得都是过渡产品，就像 QQ 也没有过渡到移动互联网时
代，或者说就是说 QQ 过渡到了
但是真正承接移动互联网时代的是微信
人和人的关系会被重构，人的社交关系会重构
那人和货物的关系呢
一样会被重构
我觉得阿里也一样有那个挑战
它特别努力
他特别努力，他加 AI 加AI 也不行
那自己再造一个产品有可能吗
就让我让下一个时代的产品诞生在我的这个公司里
所有的公司都会 all in AI
就像我当时讲的，就是说移动互联网的时候
大家都 all in 了一次这个移动互联网
我其实一直我就一直在思考一个问题
就是移动互联网对于 PC 互联网来说
到底是颠覆性创新还是延续性创新
嗯，对吧
我觉得那个是决定了问题的本质的
我当时的判断，我觉得是1
5的创新，就是它有很强的颠覆性
但它也有很强的延续性，因为它都是基于互联网的一个基本架构
嘛，它有网络效应啊这些，技术也是有有有这个啊有延续性的
但是它也有它的这个非常颠覆性的地方
所以你会看到呢，因为它的它的延续性的部分
让几家头部的互联网公司，都，过渡到了 O 运成功过渡到移
动互联网公司，但是它的颠覆性的部分最后也的确成就了抖音和
拼多多这两个更加远胜的移动互联网公司
但 AI 现在呢，我可能整体上更倾向于它是个颠覆性的技术
它都不是颠覆互联网，它都颠覆的是工业革命了
对对，就整个的就颠覆了，所以它是个生产力的革命
就互联网本质上是个生产关系的革命啊
所以它整个都颠覆了以后，延续性部分没那么强
那么在这个意义上，原有的物种去适应新的物种
就会非常困难
对啊，你的技术储备可能都不是那么线性的
所以，我既希望于下一代的产品也长在我的公司里
难度也是很高的
就是哪怕我用的不是我现在这个产品吧
我用下一个产品去承接，让它诞生在我这个公司里
这个难度也非常高
这是组织文化原因吗
不两
公司里这个难度也非常高，这是组织文化原因吗
不，两个方面，组织文化肯定是其中的一个制约啊
因为你一个10万人的公司转成 AI 原生
跟一个10个人的公司长成一个1000人的 AI 原生公司
难度是不一样的
这是非常重要的第一点
第2个就是说，这是大家对平台跟生态的理解
就是你如果没有做出第一个真正成功的 Agent
你大概率不理解 Agent 是怎么运行的
你就没有办法提供那个基础设施，成为不了那个事实上的标准
也就成为不了入口
所以你自己得在 Agent 上得真正整明白了
你才有用户，才能吸引更多的人，吸引更多的 Agent 的
开发者在你这上面开发
所以先有一个成功的 Agent 是前置条件
才有那个黑洞效应
是的，是的
你看，就是过去两年，XI 也做了很多事情啊
你觉得他们是战略错了吗
战略上可能也有问题，他们没有特别明确的方向
嗯
也不像你说到 peg 那么
给他们没有特别明确的方向，嗯，也不像 Slackpink
那么聚焦，啊，然后，我觉得组织上肯定是有问题的
我讲个细节吧，我在硅谷只要是碰到
有一群工程师的场合，XAI 的那个人
永远是最疲惫的那个人
哦
就他们最卷
对他都已经不是一般意义上的卷，就是他就是
被消耗的过度了
可能跟 Aaron 工作的那种方式也消耗人
就他虽然可能让你成长，但是可能特别消耗人
所以你看到他们来了以后，也是没有什么力气说话的
任何一个组织的创新，其实是就像人一样的
人太累的时候是没有创新的
你一定是在一个相对，开放放松的状态
你才会有新的东西出来
就当一个组织绷得那么紧，叫然后又
非常的高压的环境下，要做一件特别大的创新是件非常难的事情
嗯
而且我听研究员的评价，也没觉得
而且我听研究员的评价，也没觉得 A 软真正懂大模型
所以他原来那套方法论，就他比较偏硬件的那套方法论
其实到了这个 AI 这个时代，他没办法自己直接给答案
然后又没办法用一种共创的方式让组织来给答案
那那因为他以前都是自上而下的，对吧
是的，他给了地心原理的答案，然后逼着大家去超常规的去完成
但是这在这个场合下，他自己给不出那个答案
他又不给底下的人那么大的空间去给出一个答案
我觉得 XAS 肯定卡在组织上了
所以他这个也就是您说那个组织和战略之间的这个关系做的很差
是的，是的，嗯，他没有通过组织去生成战略
他都是他自己的意志
对
马伊塔呢
我每次都觉得小扎很年轻啊，他为什么跟不上
不是小，你年轻，但是你出头早，消耗也早啊
哦
就消耗的也多啊，因为你被一代一代的这样的东
消耗的也多，因为你被一代一代的这样的东西其实都在消耗你的
认知的潜力
而且 Meta 大到这种程度，它内部调度资源啊这些就变得
非常的困难
而且我觉得大部分的研究员也不觉得小扎懂模型
所以他就没办法真正去做非常重要的决定
然后另外两家公司，就比如说 Sam
他是真的是依赖 Ilya，然后 Ilya 是真能够驱动整
个事情的，对吧
然后 Sam 又是个很好的 CEO
所以这两个就是个很好的搭配
然后 Anthropic 是整个的组织能力非常强
然后 Dario 给这个 Vision 这方面把握的又比
较准
嗯
所以这个啊 Anthropic 就显示出了一个非常聚焦的
有 Vision 基稳的一个公司的爆发力
但是 OpenAI 因为底子够厚
所以它即使这一轮反过身来追 Anthropic 速度也非
常快
但这两家公司本质上都是新
N 刷的这个速度也非常快，但这两家公司本质上都是新时代的
创业公司，啊，所以它的组织文化各方面其实都更加匹配啊
然后，到你到这个呃，到其他几家公司
就都有各自自己的问题了
嗯，中国的公司呢，你有没有一些观察
中国公司其实也类似，本质上也类似
嗯，就 Kimi 可能就比如说更加原生一点
但是这个前文因为起步的比较早，而且有大公司的这个资源的支
持，所以它一直能够持续的往前跑啊
然后字节当张一鸣自己反应过来要 all in 下场的时候
那字节的速度也非常快
呃，中国的竞争为什么每次收敛起来都特别慢
是因为先发的企业就不像美国的企业
它有两三年的先发期，所以呢，它有一个健康酝酿 DNA 的
阶段
哦
然后中国的企业呢，呃，这
NA 的阶段哦，然后中国的企业呢
呃，至少到目前这一轮为止，还是在美国原型上的一个快速跟进
对
所以大家同时起步的话，就必然变成百团大战
嗯
因为大家看到的都是差不多的图像
然后都去硅谷把所有研究员都撸一遍
然后每个人都能挖一两个人，所以你就变成了相对容易出现同质
化竞争的
但是这里面即使是这样，这里面真正认知比较深刻的
然后可能早了那么一年跟半年的，对吧
像这个杨志林跟这个严俊杰，也包括智普
对吧
就这这几个其实更加原始，不太是那么跟上来的这批
那明显的这一轮竞争，还是他们跑在前头
现在不应该再去做大模型了吧
再去参与这种
传统意义上的大模型，我也没觉得有人在做
也不会有人投了
除非你是一个新新 lab
小红书啊
除非你是一个新新 lab，小红书啊
你还有啊，不都在做吗
没有啊，他们的核心都是做应用啊
他们都在做大模型啊，不，他们做大模型是为了补齐一些基本能
力
嗯
是为了真正去做应用的时候能够发力
这个跟其他两家公司是不一样，所以你没看到他们的团队太多出
来晒参数啊那些，对吧
它是作为未来的一个基础能力在储备的
我不觉得这两家公司愿意参加大模型作为基础设施的 API
的工厂这样的竞争
但是他们起码认为做应用的前提是我得有一个很强的模型
就下一阶段大应用的公司，那个模型跟应用技术的那个边界是不
清楚的
所以如果他们在这一代断代的太厉害
它下一代不一定接得住
嗯，对，所以这个就是我们前面讨论的应用公司要不要做模型嘛
所以它是个能力的储备
但是这个事情本身也是一个开放的讨论
它是在看实际的进展会演化到哪个阶段
嗯
就相当，这个棋是没有下到中盘的
还在开盘的布局阶段
您对今年的，就是不管是模型也好
agent 也好，机器人也好，有没有一些预测
到今年底，26年
我从来不做短期预测，我只提供一些规律性的理解供大家参考
比如说5年呢
5年我是觉得 agent 的入口肯定有可能出现了
就是第二阶段大概大概大家都能看明白了
反正移动互联网时代出现像抖音、拼多多这样的产品
要到第三阶段
对，嗯，对，就 Google、抖音、抖音跟拼多多
我觉得都是类似这样的
而且你像拼多多出来的非常晚
对
对吧
现在可能距离我们还有多少年
那个可能是8年、10年以后的事情
好漫长，但是给应用创业者提供了很多的希望
你别忘了，OpenAI 已经11年了
啊
对吧
用了 OpenAI 已经11年了
啊，对吧
我只是这两年我们感受到的是个加速度
您觉得当人工智能成为新的生产资料和基础设施
社会需要多长时间来消化这场技术革命
一代人，一代人，20年起步，因为他们才是原住民啊
那如果呃智能能像能源一样从外部获得
你觉得未来人和人的差异在哪里
我觉得是创造力的差别
所以，就德鲁克有一个非常经典的一个分析框架
他把人类社会从工业时代以来划了3个阶段啊
第一个阶段是生产力的革命，也就是流水线取代了手工作坊啊
第2个阶段呢是管理革命，大概100年前左右开始
就是有泰勒的这些科学管理方法呀
然后出现了商学院这个新物种
商学院的核心目的就是给现代化管理匹配足够多的这个管理人员
啊
对，第三阶段它叫做
这个管理人员，嗯，对，第三阶段它叫做知识革命的阶段
就是他观察到从70年代开始，软件变成一个非常重要的发展方
向，而软件的核心是处理人类的知识
啊，把知识跟最优实践通过软件的方法沉淀下来
变成一个标准的这个执行的这个这个方法
这是德鲁克，他1999年吧，大概过世了
所以看到的整个过去两个世纪的变化
啊，那么我借用他这个框架呢，我自己认为
如果从人的角度来看，AI 时代可以被定义为创造力时代
就是所有可以被结构化处理的知识
这样类型的工作都会被 AI 接管
啊，然后人一方面被逼着去开发自己新的潜能
嗯，但是你也可以讲，人终于被解放出来
可以去开发
讲人终于被解放出来，可以去开发自己的潜能
而我认为这个空间是非常大的
啊，这个方向就是创造力，就 AI 做不了的创造力的事情
啊，只不过是我们对创造力要有一个更好的理解和重新的定义
就可能创造力不是简单的会写首歌
或者会画幅画，它可能是更多的原创的定义复杂问题的能力
啊，就是比如说像这个电真正发明了以后
流水线出现了以后，才有产业工人这个概念
啊，技术工人的概念，然后才有了白领
嗯
这些，都是19世纪的人其实根本想象不到的事情
所以我觉得未来所有人努力的方向
就是开发自己的创造力
嗯，这个创造力还是一种原创造力
对，那当然了
嗯
当然，就是无中生有的能力
有的东西机器都知道啊
啊，一种无中
嗯，有的东西机器都知道啊
啊，一种无中生有的能力
对
因为如果是已经有东西的话，机器都当作 data 获取到了
对啊，对啊
嗯
这种创造可能从机器的角度来说很无聊啊
因为它可能就是各种各样的情感陪伴
人跟人之间有的没的想要的各种各样的以前没有被开发的需求
就说，也许不贡献给这个物理世界的巨大进步
但是它可能对人类的成长跟幸福感有很多的帮助
就是这个东西是可能有很多种以前我们没想过的方法
嗯，哎，刚才说如果公司会消失，那商学院会消失吗
商学院已经不行了，都在衰落了
现在的整个围绕着公司建立的，比如说办公室啊
就这些可见的是不是都会发生巨大的变化
都会啊，都会啊，因为虚拟世界的比例会越来越高
虚拟世界的比例会越来越高
嗯
对啊
就 Metaverse 的那个方向是
嗯，对呀，就 Meta Verse 的那个方向是没错的
可能只是时间早了5年而已
哦，那未来，人作为一个社会来说
你能看到什么样的变化
是会发生天翻地覆的变化
就我碰到的一些00后的创业者，想做这个土系应用的
嗯，那他们想象的世界，完全不是我们现在能够理解的世界
嗯，太有意思了
我觉得今天还是带来了对未来非常积极乐观的
我是比较乐观的，我一直觉得就要有有巨大的发展空间
会不会改变整个的教育体制呢
如果对人的能力的需求发生的变化
一定会的
以前的教育体制还是一种智商激励
它本质是知识的灌输嘛，嗯，智商的开发都是第二位的
嗯，知识的灌输是第一位的，那这个肯定是不行的
对吧
你像看我们从小到大有多少兴趣被压抑了
然后我们并没有顺着一个开放的、探索的这条路径去开发我们的
潜能发我们的潜能
我们都在最早的时间，为了不输在起跑线上
被摁在了原来世界的固定模式里头
所以，我觉得接下来最大的冲突，就是教育
教育系统的冲突
因为，其实年轻人已经知道，未来跟我们今天想象的完全不一样
嗯
所以，你你随便问高中生，他们大概都知道
用现在的方法，大学毕业以后找工作都找不着
他们可能有很多的想象，但是我们肯定不敢让他们
去走他们的路
啊，所以他们就卡在这了
但你问更年轻的家长，那我刚生下来的小孩该该怎么教育
他肯定知道要用新的方法教育，他只是不知道用什么方法教育而
已
所以，这是一个，它特别需要接下来整个社会
花很大的资源跟力气去探索的方向
无中生有的能力
对啊
这个总结的很好
是的，是的
嗯
有的 AI 都有人需要做无中生有
是的
人和系统的关系，人和系统的关系
人和 AI 的关系，未来会怎么演变
我觉得会是一个在组织里头非常明确
是一个深度协同的关系
社会层面，至少我们不谈 ASI
就是超级人工智能会长成啥样，反正大家也没共识
就我们也先不谈那些
就是在这一轮能看到 AGI 时代
它肯定会渗透到社会的方方面面，就像在过去10年我们已经离
不开手机一样的
就说将来每个人身上某个地方挂一个摄像头
有一个语音接收的设备，然后可穿戴的东西满身都是
加上外骨骼之类的，人就成了一个加强版的人
嗯，这个我觉得是完全可以想象的
嗯，有看到好的硬件公司吗
硬件产品
硬件产品其实也是这一两年的热点
就是各种各样的消费硬件都在层出不穷
就像我们讲的，就是00年以后大家都在做电器、家用电器
但是最后能立足的是那几个大品类
家用电器，但是最后能立住的是那几个大品类
还有无数的小品类
嗯
不知道会是什么，现在
就像像美国很早出现的那个烤面包机的那个
大家现在还用的，那个也是很早被发明出来的
但是那个不够大，技术不够复杂，所以它没法养一个大公司
所以就是说，有很多的这种新的公司
其实就就是讲的一切都会被重新来一次
嗯
但是哪些是大东西，哪些是小东西
哪些是主，哪些是辅，然后谁用哪种方法找到了面向未来的密码
嗯
这个都是不确定的，但是我觉得有个基本态度要改变啊
就是原来我们倾向于降低不确定性
但是我觉得在这个阶段，其实是要拥抱不确定性
不确定性就是最大的机会
嗯
所以心心态先得改了，就不能恐惧
就你见到不确定性，见到复杂性就恐惧
你就肯定没法往前走了
但是面对巨大的不不确定性
肯定没法往前走，但是面对巨大的不不确定性跟复杂性
你觉得特别好玩，特别有机会去创造一些新东西
我觉得那才是年轻的一代的这些创业者的心态
我们有点杞人忧天了，我们替他们担心的太多了
哎，曾明老师，您自己的使命是什么呀
我觉得就是做一个快乐的研究员啊
快乐的研究员
对，我觉得在现在的这个语境下是挺有挺有趣的一个定位
嗯，快乐的研究员，嗯，对
AI 会让人类更快乐吗
我至少是这么希望的
这是大家讲 AI 上山啊这些，但是但是就是说
它肯定会带来一系列的新的问题了
嗯
就但是整体上，有些更哲学的层面上我们可以去探讨
但是抛开哲学层面，文明的进步就是技术不断的带来新的可能性
然后人驾驭好了新的技术，进入一个新的文明发展阶段
新文明比旧文明对人来说，快乐指数是提升的还是降低的
如果在哲学层面上来说，不好说
但是从一般的衡量指标上来说，肯定是进步的
嗯，就你想看，你假如现在没有空调
你会是啥感觉
啊，然后当你在农业时代温饱一直是几万年的问题的话
那工业时代基本上把温饱这个问题在规模化的解决掉了
嗯，然后消费时代解决了消费不足的问题
啊，现在基本上都是供给过剩嘛
我们现在的核心在至少在物理产品产品上基本上都是供给过剩的
阶段
然后互联网解决了这个信息不对称的问题
解决了全天下的人都可以共享的这个问题
所以又又往前进了一大步
嗯，那 AI 肯定是，当我们有了这么多智能解决方案以后
我们就可以做一些更有趣的事情
好，以后一个组织的评判标准之一是能不能让人更快乐
能身处其中的人
从谷歌开始就是这样啊，就说大家现在可能没有体感
就说其实0708年的谷歌在硅谷是神一样的存在
比今天的那两家公司还要影响力大
就才有那么多人去参观谷歌，为了去食堂蹭顿饭
感受一下他们的氛围
然后所有最优秀的人都是要去谷歌
嗯，其实它当时它的氛围本质上就是尊重人的差异化
释放人的创造力，让你有20%的时间可以干你自己想干的事情
给你们提供最好的食堂，对吧
就就所以它的当时的那个文化，其实谷歌是最早提出来
隐隐约约的感觉到了未来的，所以他们是最早提出来
就那还叫互联网时代，其实是需要新的文化
需要新的组织方式的，对呀，嗯，那个趋势会继续延续下去
哎，我很好奇啊，典型的曾鸣教授的一天是什么样的呀
做一个快乐的研究员，其实就是第第一个快乐的研究员
其实就是第第一个就是跟创业者聊
对吧
然后看看他们最新的想法
呃，第2个就是看看最新的资讯，看看类似你们这样的访谈
因为的确帮我帮我省了很多事情
就现在能够看到很完整的一个思想的对话
所以等于说我有很多的信息的输入
可以做数据训练，让自己不那么累
不那么辛苦
要不然的话，就其实我觉得今年上半年
大部分人都已经有个深刻的感受，就是说你很容易因为 AI
的工具如此高效率，把你自己弄得极为疲惫
因为你根本跟不上它的处理速度
所以其实现在大家都开始反应过来
要有一些格局，然后怎么找到作为一个生物的人的一个合理的节
奏，再去跟 AI 找一个新的平衡
我这边还有一些快问快答，全球范围内一道你喜欢的食物
我们是为了
全球范围内一道您喜欢的食物，我们是为了在这个硅基生命到来
之前留下更多的碳基文明的记忆啊
辣椒炒肉
嗯，全球范围内一个你喜欢的地点
目前可能还是上海
您平时会读 AI 论文吗
你觉得影响过 AI 进程的重要的论文是什么
我没有读 AI 的技术论文
基于当下的认知，一个关键的重要的 bet 是什么
出现一个足够好用的 to c 的agent
我们公司叫语言级世界工作室
当您第一次听到这个名字的时候，您会想什么
你可能要改成字的体级世界
可以分享几本书吗
就是您的人生之书，就是真的对你产生过很大的影响的
我觉得就就管理学上比较基本的，像这个吉野长清的系列的那几
本书，然后像德鲁克的书，嗯，然后还有我本科的时候基本上全
文抄了的一本书，就是因为摘录太多了
基本上抄了的一本书，就是因为摘录太多了
基本上抄了这本书，是弗里德曼的关于市场基本运营机制的一本
书
哦
不厚，但是特别精彩，所以那个建立了我对市场的基本运行机制
的理解
您觉得是什么让您对管理学发生这么深厚的兴趣
呃，战略学
我其实高中的时候就放弃了理科的这个参加这些奥数竞赛那些
因为我们那时候大概是第一届文理分科
然后我其实更加喜欢历史啊、人文啊这些东西
所以我虽然当时也算年级第一，可以去走那条路
但我觉得那个是对我来说我不感兴趣
所以我其实高中时候就放弃了
嗯
然后到了大学以后，选了经济以后
发现我们学的经济经济学的数学要求超过大部分的工科
嗯
我就觉得太无聊了，所以我后面读博士的时候
最后就选了这个商学院，对吧
而且战略这样的比较宏观的，然后在真实是
而且战略这样的比较宏观的，然后在真实世界跟理论世界
有不得不建立连接的一个学科，我觉得这个就比较好玩
战略是一个组织大脑，这必须要 CEO 来做
你觉得战略做的好人，CEO 一般是什么样的人
之间有关系吗
所以创始人里面，有战略能力的并不多
就真正走得远的，就刚刚讲的使命驱动、愿景驱动、战略驱动
就能走到战略驱动的就已经是很优秀的了
但不是卓越的
对，卓越的可能严格讲得是使命驱动的才有可能走向卓越
但有的人可能是先有愿景，然后慢慢发展出使命；有的人是天生
就比较使命驱动，或者就是你形成非常难得的一个团队里面有那
么一两个人形成很好的互补，就一个人可能战略能力强一点
一个人动手能力强一点，就有点像王兴跟王慧文那种这种这种组
合，也是很难得的一个组合
自己属于什么驱动啊
这个还不好说，因为我跟张一鸣个人交流不多
所以我
所以我对他使命的那一个那一段有没有
我没法判断
但是张一鸣是一个是一个了不起的天才
是属于他有自己的管理哲学的
嗯
然后他至少是愿景驱动，然后有完整的自己对组织的理解
包括他最早提出来公司级产品，这个已经非常领先了
包括比如说我原来讲这个 Netflix
就奈飞的文化，嗯，大部分人第一反应是中国人做不到
因为那个文化太美国跟硅谷了
但是字节是最早，基本上在跟上，跟这个网飞的文化是非常非常
相似的
但字节最后做成了一个效率工厂
因为他东西都整明白了以后，剩下的在战略这个执行阶段就追求
效率了
所以他的 AI 战略要张一鸣重新下场
再重新定义
就任何一个公司到了最后都是追求效率
因为你战略越来越清晰
因为你战略越来越清晰，剩下的就是执行任务了
但是，就是我们刚才讲的，组织的宿命就是时代一定会变化
让你原来那套不适合，所以你要不就彻底转型
要不就被时代淘汰
对每个人都很公平，新的时代，对这个听起来是个好消息